yo what's
up everybody oh my goodness
what a stream this is gonna be this is a
very very special stream because
i am joined by a very special person and
his name
is peter france everybody what is going
on what dude
up son dude it is good to be here i'm
excited to
dig my fingers into some studio ghibli
renders and make a
make a sweet scene thanks for having me
man yeah dude absolutely um so hey can
you guys hear us
can you see us okay just give me some
like thumbs ups in the chat so we know
that we're all good
yeah this was quite an ordeal yeah it
was we were like
oh man yeah maybe we could like figure
it out uh like last night but then
we were up so late working on the star
wars thing um
that like we're like oh man we're so
tired so we woke up this morning there's
always so much to do on the morning of a
stream it's crazy
but we're getting thumbs ups right now
we got the live chat popping off uh hell
yeah
yeah the coffee got the live stream
we're good to go yeah
all right so what are we what are we
doing today dude what are we gonna do
dude
that's a good question i i well we're
gonna do a studio ghibli render yeah
because these movies are lovely and
beautiful but
i i personally don't know which studio
giveaway movie or
which scene i'm going to do so i got to
look at some reference to figure that
out
for sure do you have stuff pulled up
right now yeah i got like some youtube
cops
some compilations going all right here
i'm gonna switch over to you so i'm
looking at your blender right now yeah
there you go
sweet dude this stuff is nuts
i could just spend these three hours oh
my god dude
just watching this ah that looks so nice
it's amazing
it's like not okay yeah it's like
their stuff is so painterly and i'm like
to do it in 3d and to do it like all for
real which is kind of like water it down
you know i know yeah it would just like
make it look real yeah but i don't know
maybe we can figure something out
um no totally i mean oh god damn
what are you thinking about do you have
do you have a movie or a scene in mind
yeah so here um let's see
bam all right so i got a bunch
of images here pulled from like back
when i was working at rocket jump
i like pulled a bunch of images from
nice bunch of movies and the ghibli ones
were definitely
one of those um those look great i'm
looking at the stream right here oh heck
yeah so
i got the like panorama ones going like
these big ones
oh dang yeah that's amazing oh my
goodness
where'd you get these images i just
pulled them from the movie yeah i just
like print screen
and then went into photoshop and just
pasted them in
that's amazing those are beautiful yeah
they're freaking sick man
so i don't know i wanna what's up
nothing so i don't know dude i want to
like
i want to i want to do all of these
they're also i think we have time we can
spend a few days on the stream yeah
absolutely we'll just do a 24-hour
ghibli stream dude
be craziness yeah um it'd be cool to do
like this robot with the grass on them
oh man that could be said it looks like
freaking iron giant dude
straight up yeah or i was thinking about
these
beautiful is it from castle in the sky
uh
it's hard because i want to pick one
that's like really complex and has a lot
going on
but i i've learned that lesson too many
times
for sure gotta pick an attainable goal
what about
there's this one of the bath house
that's like like the daytime main one
no it's like a night rainy night time
one i'm trying to find it oh yeah i was
looking at that one
the heck is it it's like here
you have it on your side somewhere yeah
let's see
i'm going to you is it uh
this one very similar it's not that one
it's like
it's like a random shot in the middle of
like
the middle of the movie it's like a
transition shot or something
damn i'm trying to find it yeah you keep
looking i'm on
i'm on you right now all right um oh i
found it this one's really nice
oh you got it yeah dude that is
beautiful though oh my god
it's it's ridiculous all right this one
um right here
you see that it's like rainy oh oh
dude you should do that one okay i feel
like that's your vibe
i'm gonna do this one yeah i'm doing
this one for sure
awesome all right so i'm going back to
you you got to figure out what the heck
you're going to do because we only have
like we got like two hours
to work on this you know oh boy okay
you know i love these daytime like blue
sky shots with lots of green
that's really calling my name so i'm
gonna find one of those okay cool
heck yeah um so real quick shout outs to
christian thank you for the super chat
and also josh he's josh is like
pop off sons i'm like heck yeah
dude thanks y'all yeah that's awesome
um so once you get your scene chosen
here
um we uh
actually here how about this how about
this this uh we got a sponsor today on
today's stream
so while the sponsor's going peter go
ahead and choose your scene
and then uh we'll be back in like two to
three minutes and we'll hop right into
these renders guys
so uh so stay tuned oh yeah yeah back in
two minutes let's do it
today's stream is brought to you by
vagin.io wagon provides you with a
number of computers at different tech
specs
to access from anywhere in the world so
wagon's a bit different from other
remote access companies that allow you
to tap
into your personal supercomputer what if
you don't have a personal supercomputer
and that's exactly where wagon comes in
so let me give you guys a brief rundown
on how this works
so once you guys log in you'll be
presented with your dashboard here you
can check your connection
tweak some other settings here but most
importantly you can actually
choose your tech specs so let's start
with planet we got four cores 16
gigabytes on the gpu
and 16 gigs of ram we'll save that and
we'll run the computer
boom and we're in this computer is a
blank
computer obviously i mean it comes with
a couple things pre-installed here
but this computer is yours and yours
alone to download and install
whatever the heck you guys want you are
the only one with access to your
personal
wagon computer so i know we got a lot of
blender fans here on the channel so i'm
going to use vegan's file
transfer option to drag and drop a
blender scene from my personal computer
to our new vegan computer all right
there we go let's let's open this bad
boy up
so even on wagon's cheapest computer
it's actually not that bad we're in like
render view here
um we could sit here we could render
this but what if we actually
wanted to render it on a more powerful
computer on a computer that renders
things
faster let's see what that would look
like so i'm going to go ahead and log
off of this computer
and change our computer to galaxy this
is 48 cores
four 16 gigabyte gpus and 192 gigabytes
of ram we'll save and we'll run the
computer
and we're back in so this is actually an
entire
other computer but it has the files that
we dragged and dropped
onto the original let's go ahead and
open it up and we'll hit f12 and
get this render going so what's cool
about this is you can actually render
this
on your wagon computer while you
continue to work on your personal
computer at home
so i'll just go ahead and log out and
let this render while we continue
working
so vegan is here to provide you guys
with additional computing power for your
projects
and if you want to get into 3d but don't
have a super computer yet this might be
a good way to get
started so guys head on over to vegan.io
and get your renders going
all right heck yeah good stuff
very good stuff all righty um that was
that was
a great brand segment my dude
[Laughter]
thank you yeah that was actually cool
man i got this whole like i'm figuring
out the stream situation you know
um making it more professional feeling
good
um yeah vegan they're super chill been
awesome to work with so
uh shout outs for sure give them a shout
and uh peter do you have your scene do
you have
you have what you're gonna do i have my
freaking scene
i do here let me let me pull it up yeah
i'm going to you
[Music]
so here's a really low res screenshot
but i'm gonna do this scene i believe
is this from freaking princess mononoke
i
am very unfamiliar with these movies
i've seen like half of them
oh for sure do you know which movie this
is from i don't it like i
it's definitely not from princess
mononoke this might be from like the
secret world of arietti or something
oh okay there's a couple that his um his
son did
that i heard were like not as good um so
i kind of didn't watch them but i
totally should yeah it's from arietti we
got it
yeah it's from okay confirmed gotcha
yeah i mean honestly regardless of the
movie it's from it's it's gorgeous and
so i'm gonna do this one
you guys are just gonna be mega scan
city yeah gotta get the gut race
all right so you'll do that one and i'll
do
this one here um
yeah dude dude i'm so excited to see
that one mega scan city too
[Laughter]
all right let me know what would we do
without mega scans oh dude it'd be
horrible it'd be a rough life
like no doubt i'd be out on the street
um okay so let's talk about
like what is going to be complicated
with with this here with with my render
um i'm looking at the roof and i'm
looking i'm feeling like
uh mega skans has
some of that roof tiling we can pull oh
totally yeah
um i feel like the hardest part is just
going to be modeling that
intricate building geometry it's just
blocks though
i mean getting the details on the wood
paneling for sure like most definitely
that's a good point
but like i wonder how i'm gonna do the
people
because it's all about like the people
inside it's cool oh yeah
yeah i mean maybe you could do like a
google image search for some stills from
the movie
and do like a quick roto cut them out
and then stick them in as
cards or something oh yeah i could see
that um
also getting the rain like you see how
like the rain haze
is kind of hitting the ceiling and stuff
like i wonder how to yeah how are you
gonna do that
i don't know maybe that's photoshop
maybe it's um
like right i i mean people would say
just just do it in cops
or whatever
yeah we did a freaking thing with people
um
he came into the office that freaking
guy it's gonna be crazy i'm not gonna
say too much
because just look forward to some fun
people content it's gonna be
freaking crazy yeah um
but um let's let's check out your scene
peter
what sweet what are you looking at here
like what's gonna be difficult
for you on this one sweet yeah i mean
the thing i
i think i'm gonna struggle with the most
is just the composition because
these scenes aren't real 3d scenes i
mean they have 3d perspective
but it's not like you couldn't use
f-spy or something to get the exact
focal length and composition you kind of
have to cheat it in a painterly way so
i'm just gonna like
make it like a telephoto lens maybe like
a 50 mil or something like that and then
i'm gonna start
laying out planes first i'm going to go
can i draw on this
so i'm going to go and do this ground
first get this kind of
curved area here and then this curved
area
make sure i have a nice flat plane for
the water over here and then i'm gonna
go
and make the medium-sized shapes you
know this little thing right here
kind of block out some of the foliage
this little cliff thingy
um just get the general shape of the
scene first and then once that's done
i'm going to go in and start adding
trees and shrubs and then i think the
last step will be getting these
god rays and these little flowers right
here
because that's what it's all about
that's like the cherry on top
dude that's great that was like so well
said
is this just the most beautiful
composition right here
[Laughter]
dude with all these red lines yeah
seriously it's great though man it's
freaking great um
holy crap yo we're at 577 people right
now dude
that's like yes that's almost a record
um
sweet okay all right so uh peter here's
what we're gonna do
i think since everyone usually watches
me stream in c4d
they they know what's up i'm gonna start
on you all right we're gonna start
in blender we got a lot of blender fans
going
um sweet so yeah i'll just have you kick
it off here and start building out your
scene we'll be building the background
alongside you we'll switch back over to
me when uh
when i got something but yeah dude let's
do it let's do it
heck yeah son all right i'm pumped okay
so we got blender open here the first
thing i'm gonna do is bring in
our reference image
sweet okay all right
dude i'm kind of nervous to follow up a
studio ghibli screenshot i i gotta do it
justice you know
oh absolutely cool so i'm just gonna
start out with a little plane here
oh nice you have your reference like in
blender itself
oh yeah yeah i like doing that so then i
don't have to switch windows or anything
like that
it's really nice first i'm gonna do
these little
hills right here get like a really rough
representation so it can kind of eyeball
the composition of the scene
all right i must say we we did hit a
record peter an all-time high yeah
631 people in the stream guys oh heck
yeah
son it is climbing it's like 40 like
it's climbing up right now
that's great nice
okay so we got our rough geometry here
let me add a camera
how much do you narrate these like mo
every time like everything dude my
throat is so sore at the end of these
streams because i'm just like talking
for five hours straight sometimes
oh my goodness it's craziness
okay
camera calibrator that's what okay i'm
doing i'm doing uh
you said f spy that's basically
something where you line up perspective
to your reference right yeah yeah if
y'all watching don't know there's this
awesome free software called
f spy where if you want to like
perfectly match up the angle of a shot
that you already have
you just load it into the software you
give it like
four lines in perpendicular directions
and then it's just like bam it gives you
the focal length of the camera
it gives you the exact position and
rotation it's amazing and then you can
just import that into blender
or probably other 3d software and it
just sets up your scene for you
it's wonderful yeah i think i think
blender guru is the first person i heard
about that from when he was like
recreating uh gone girl or something
right yeah dude shout out to freaking
andrew price
dude that guy's a champ that's a
first-year son
i still like i don't even use blender
and i watch his videos it's he's like
he's so good
i i really appreciate how his videos are
more theory based
and less actual like practice
based it's really nice yeah his latest
um like cabin in the woods one was so
good dude
yeah that video
i think ren said he's gonna pop by too
oh no way
that'd be awesome yeah like in the chat
i think we'll have to make him a mod
around here somewhere yeah so i got the
scene going and it looks super jakey
right now
so i'm actually going to overlay the
background image on top of my scene so i
can
like do a pixel perfect
there we go okay so oh that's awesome
dude this is fun i'm pumped
all right
it's all about that first block out you
know yeah so you want to look up for
success
yeah you start as as general as possible
like
get the big blocks kind of locked in and
then you go in for the mediums like you
said
yeah whenever i start small like with
the detail i'm just like i get halfway
through
and it just falls apart yeah because
you're like i just zoomed in on that and
then when i zoom out i'm like i didn't
need to do any of that
yeah spend your time on the on the big
stuff first it's literally a sketch
like an artist's sketch before they
start a drawing or a painting you know
yeah totally
okay this is jank i'm starting over here
all right i'm gonna switch over to me
real quick cool
so basically like
like we were talking about f spy is for
blender but cinema has its own deal
basically if you have a
your camera you right click your camera
and go to what
where is it tracker tags
the camera calibrator so you add that
you load in your image right here
boom i got my reference right here is
what i'm doing and we're going to
calibrate it so we add those lines like
like peter was saying
um same technique different program
so let's line this up let's do the
y-axis no you know what
we got a good x-axis line right here
across the rooftop let's just
line that up and then if you hold shift
and click this line it'll it'll like
determine what it is known
length x so this is x it's red that's
exactly what we want
um let's add another one because you for
perspective usually you got like
these lines don't just go in the same
direction they do in the world but not
to the camera like
it might be a wider angle lens and it'll
open up a bit wider so
shift click that's x and you can see x
vanishing point boom solved
um let's add another line let's try and
find the y axis on these guys
right there shift click y-axis
not solved yet but let's just add
another line and it probably will solve
no problem
um sipo yo what's up dude thanks for the
super chat
appreciate you brother um
you're stuck in exams that sucks um
saipo says hey peter really enjoyed your
mushroom forest
um he's anthony's yeah heck yeah
thanks man i i really appreciate that
i'm glad you enjoyed it
with that custom music too man that's
freaking sick
thanks yeah i i want to get back into
music i haven't done it in a while
super fun what program do you use
i use logic which is kind of a bummer i
had to like buy
a separate computer to make music on
because you can't use it on windows
oh seriously yeah dude that's crazy
i don't know
dude 732 people in the freaking
livestream holy crap dude
heck yeah that's awesome son
all right so i got this stuff solved you
can see everything's yellow
um that means we got oh nice things
solved and i should be able to make a
cube
and the cube like
lives basically in that perspective so
if i go back here
oh baby i should be able to just load
up a background
let me see
load up a background let's save your
freaking work dude have you saved yet
i have not that is a good idea oh my god
all right boom arthur yo what's up dude
thank you again
for the super chat that's freaking
awesome he says what's up y'all
um love your stuff at corridor thanks
for all the knowledge peter
you should let your patrons know you're
here
[ __ ] you're right i did put on my
instagram that's good
that's good yeah
all right this is boring stuff i'm just
gonna load in a background let's go back
to you peter
what you got going on right here son
sounds good i got a freaking cube dude
nice all right so i've somewhat
successfully
lined up the camera in this scene let me
bring that down a bit actually there we
there we go now we're vibing so we got
our
cliff in the back here we got empties
representing our hill
actually you know what this is like
still so off this is so difficult
matching this
but you know what we're gonna do it
we're not getting up yet
isn't it like kind of hard on a stream
too where like you feel like you have to
like
be entertaining the whole time and you
feel rushed like do you feel a little
rushed
oh absolutely i'm feeling the pressure
right now
i'm a little shaky i know me too i'm
kind of cold
yeah it's it's nice and gloomy here in
l.a today
i know you're getting that gloom over
over near yeah absolutely man i think it
might rain at noon
pretty soon here oh maybe it was raining
last night apparently
yep i love rain man we don't get enough
of it
i know
all right i think it's time to start
sculpting so i have my rough scene laid
out here
you can see matching the background
somewhat
and the perspective isn't entirely jank
i mean it's a little it's death
honestly a little [ __ ] maybe this should
be a bit bigger and further away
there we go that's better yeah i'm
trying to get my scale right now okay so
i'm going to go into
sculpt mode subdivide this a little bit
back into sculpt mode and let's just
start
sculpting yeah turn down the strength
it's going to sculpt this ground here to
match the scene
a little bit right there
cool cool cool
i'm gonna add some more resolution
sweet get that little spot
awesome
sweet yeah we're looking good nice dude
all right we have the rough scene laid
out
i think i should do some water next to
add that plane
oh my god those subs a lot of
subdivisions
oh
yo what up todd thank you
for the super chat man yeah todd's
having a good time he's 37.
todd the god todd the freaking god dude
he's learning blender he's 37 um
learn 3d modeling yeah um so he's
digging that right now yeah
dude so many people are talking to me
and they're like i want to learn blender
but it's just so much work
i'm like yeah but if you just spend like
20 minutes a day
then you and you take the pressure off
yourself of being
good you just like do a little bit every
day and then in
three months before you know it you can
like do a ton of stuff
that you would have never been able to
do if you'd never started yeah seriously
um it's all about those like bite-sized
little bits consistently
and that's how you get better at
anything um
i really like uh blender guru's video on
like the habits
of effective artists and just never
having a zero percent day
you know whether it's just like drawing
a line or just like
making one cube in blender when you by
the time you get there you'll probably
want to do a little bit more
yeah yeah i never have the zero percent
day that's a really really good point
um also too i think like why are you
trying to get into this
you know like why do you want to 3d
model stuff why do you want to learn
blender i think that's a good
like answer it's a good question to
answer you got to have like a
i think the stronger your answer the
more
the more passionate you'll be about it
and the more you'll stick to your goals
you know
that's a really interesting point i'd
never thought of it like that before
because like if it's like oh just
whatever you just want to learn it
because like oh like someone
didn't thought it was cool versus like
this speaks to me so much
and i have so much fun doing this and i
know that if i can do this then like
you know maybe it'll set myself up for a
career
um yeah for a creative career and if you
know you're a creative person
then that's like what what you have to
ask the question like
what would happen if you didn't learn
blender like what
what would happen if you didn't do you
know daily practice in blender
like two years down the line or just
like 3d you know not just blender but
like three years down the line like
how would you be different how much more
valuable would you be in like
yeah it's all it's all good stuff to
think about that's really interesting
man
that's a great way to look at it arturo
what up son yo
peter the chat wants a discord too all
right so i got a discord
um it's just a create with clint discord
we do weekly challenges and stuff but it
looks like people want
a peter discord too damn i i honestly
didn't know like having discords was a
thing until
you told me about yours yeah dude you
you would pop off you have like a
blender
like a super blender like discord that'd
be sick man
that would be fun i don't know it seems
like a lot of pressure i i
tend to be very anti-social i mean it's
chill like you just get the community
going and like
you know give them fun challenges and
stuff like
yeah that's cool that's a good time all
right yeah yeah i'll think about doing
that
um all right i'm going back back to my
end here i'm blocking out this uh
this freaking thing so i'm just i got my
cube on x-ray mode
boom i got my camera lined up here so it
like perfectly lines up and i got my
image on a background so i'm just gonna
like block this out like peter's doing
right now
same deal it's the same process you know
different programs
same idea so it really doesn't matter
what program you guys are using as long
as you're making cool stuff you can see
how like the process is similar
throughout all of this
dang son friggin chat chats are off nice
chain
right now dude off the hook um
tila and mac thanks for the super chat
we appreciate you guys
um am i gonna try toon shading in octane
maybe
maybe not i don't know i messed with it
be cool um
and then mac you say you want to say
thank you you guys
quarter i've been inspiring for years my
favorite thing to do in my free time
heck yeah
keep it up damn damn exactly the
z zach and mack the freaking
i can't think of a rhyme but they're
really cool
the freaking the paper stack dude the
paper stick
there you go um zach wants to say thanks
for popular
popularizing blender peter um and
showing how cool it is
oh dude blender is the freaking best man
it's just oh i
i could go on and on about it but it's
just such a great software and it's only
going to get better because the people
who use it are the people who make it
you know you're not answering to any
shareholders
or having to make money on new features
or anything it's just the people who
love
it are working on it making it great and
i'm very passionate about it
that's sick man like there's a there's a
lot of cool stuff about blender
um that would be fun
you know like c4d is fun i'm very happy
in c4d
um but like if i was
like if i if i didn't know anything
about 3d and
i could choose like where do i go from
here like blender would be the first
place i'd go
it does have a great community which is
nice for beginners you know there's a
really
really active subreddit where people are
always posting stuff and answering
questions and
it's a really friendly vibe which is
nice that's awesome dude
but yeah i mean at the end of the day
it's all the same all this 3d software
it does like exactly the same thing it
just comes down to
preference and kind of just happenstance
whatever you start on i guess
yeah yeah exactly
like this block out stuff is probably
it's it's like one of the most important
steps because
this really if you can get your block
out looking nice then
[Music]
like you're kind of off to the races
really um because then you have
you've set yourself up for for a
successful
you know concept or a successful piece
of art
um totally yeah it's the bones the
it's the foundation of the house yeah
100 yo did you save did you save
recently
i'm saving every 10 seconds my fingers
are just
terminally like on control and s
like you know like when you're playing
video games it's wasd oh yeah when
you're working on 3d stuff it's just
control s
yeah yeah exactly um
good god euclid thank you thank you for
the chat dude um
he's working in triple a games as a hard
surface artist
switch to blender from maya for about 90
of things now thanks peter
wow that's awesome i'm switching back to
you son
where are you at i'm good i got my block
out going i'm going to start adding in
the
medium-sized objects which are going to
be this uh we got some shrubs here
some shrubs there we got these little
cements
i guess going through like you know you
you model your thing three material on
it and then
you can go into sculpt mode and sculpt
all these little details in there to
catch the light like on the edge of the
surface and stuff
it's really nice it's really fun process
it feels very painterly you know doing
your brush strokes and everything
that's super yeah i'm very excited for
that that's awesome
i'm going to throw in these it's a
cylinder
let's see we want some
i guess i'll just do this
would you say is like a tip right for
beginner
artists whether they're using blender or
not
what would you say is like something
that you wish you would have known
oh that's a good question really i guess
that's
more in the just stick with it category
of advice
but like never have a zero percent day
even if it's just like carve out like 10
minutes
at the end of each day to just hop in
and at the very least it'll help you
retain your knowledge you know if you
have
a few weeks where you kind of fall off
you're busy with other stuff that's
totally fine you know
nobody's saying you have to learn
everything in one go but just to hop in
there and brush up a little bit so you
don't lose any of that knowledge
is definitely going to be helpful in the
long run
that's legit yeah consistency man so
freaking important i guess that's what
it boils down to it's just consistency
in anything um like really anything
you're doing
yeah and also just finding a way to love
it like if you find a way
to have a really good time doing it then
you'll want to come back and it'll be
easy
you know like i've been working on games
recently in unreal engine and i
i can't like i find myself staying up to
like 3am just
messing around with stuff because it's
so freaking fun you know
and so just finding a way to make it fun
for yourself like whether it's the
subject of
what you're working on you know stuff
like this working on a studio ghibli
scene
like it doesn't have to be you don't
have to post anything it doesn't have to
be
even good just finding something that's
fun to work on will keep you coming back
that's a legit a legit point dude
yeah you have it has to be playful and
it has to be fun if you're like dreading
it
then it's gonna be tough
yeah totally where's my school so hard
for people dude
like dude i was a horrible student
i was i was okay you know like i really
just like loved hanging out with my
friends
it was a good time yeah
but yeah it really can be very clinical
sometimes
better when things are fun
yeah totally yeah it makes you want it
more
makes you work harder yeah
all right sweet i got my little a little
cement cylinders in here big
chilling i'm just going to create a
little
cube this isn't going to be my final
shrub
this is just so i can get the general
shape
block out the scene a little more that's
crazy so you're like you're making these
shrubs from
is that going to be your final like mesh
or are you going to replace it with
uh with something yeah i actually um
took some 3d scans
of shrubs that i'm going to put on my
patreon
and uh i i think i'll throw that in
there see how that works
it's it's surprising because you think
like 3d scanning a plant
wouldn't work because there's so much
little detail that i wouldn't be able to
capture
and that's true but it does get most of
it
it's very surprising and if you use it
like in the background of a shot it
totally works
it's wonderful that's awesome
3d scans are so legit man like i feel
like that's the way to do people too
um because you know you can always tell
when it's a 3d person in a scene you're
like oh i can just tell
but if it's a photo scan it's like so
much better
absolutely yeah ian hubert on his
patreon has
like an animated crowd asset and a bunch
of 3d scanned people
he's putting some amazing stuff on there
like honestly don't subscribe to my
patreon subscribe to ian hooper's
patreon
because i've put like some stuff on
there and i think it's good stuff but he
is just like every day puts up something
new that's like
actually super valuable so don't
subscribe to me subscribe to him
oh i mean ian is basically the blender
god but you're also like
the blender god too so it's kind of it
goes both ways dude
yeah i i kind of feel bad now uh doing
patreon i thought i work at corridor
because i'm like
i i'm making a decent living wage i
i've paused the billing on my patreon
for the last two months
because like i kind of feel bad taking
people's money you know
i hear that man yeah i think like people
are people are gonna be a fan of you
though
um no matter what they're gonna they're
gonna be a fan of peter so
um but i i hear you at the same time
dude yeah i hear you
no there's something to that you know i
i do have certain artists
that like even if they are you know
making good money i want to support them
because i really like what they're doing
and it makes me feel like
i have a hand in what they're doing you
know
yeah 100
all right
so i'm just still blocking out on my end
um let me switch over here
it's the block out you got to get the
block out right you know um
yeah once you do that it's kind of
then then you're free then you're free
to like roam
and and like really start
building out some cool stuff um
yeah that's when you can start like
experimenting and stuff yeah and it'll
come together
like it's kind of like an exponential
growth situation where it comes together
in the end like crazy super fast
totally
let's see so i want to get this like
roof piece going so maybe we bring
this point or this whole line actually
some basic modeling going on here
let's just kind of get that in the
corner and then we can pull this
out i'm holding ctrl make new stuff make
new geo there
and then you can
use the bridge tool
oh bridge that there's that
and then to optimize you can select uh
go to point mode control a select
everything
points we have 12 points total and
selected hit uo
and if there's any doubled up points
then you'll see it here
you can also hit alt v to bring up this
little dialog
and go to hud and you can just check
whatever info you want
i like having fps up here and the you
know faces and points and that kind of
stuff to make it
make it easier to see what you got going
on
all right so if i go to camera view like
that's looking okay like
it's a little off a little off
we get this stuff back in and we're
starting to feel
the shape of this thing and if i render
it
and get like a temporary hdri
go in let's do like uh just a color not
even a
image is fine and we'll pull
it was like a kind of like a dark
bluish green color somewhere like
somewhere in there arturo
what's up dude thank you for the super
chat he says don't listen to peter
subscribe to his patreon so we can keep
fulfilling it with knowledge
[Laughter]
and uh and to join the dickson award
yeah man
you should do discord to be sick dude
all right yeah i'm done
okay i'm wondering how much of this i
can actually fill out
with like uh
like the qixel bridge assets
you know because they have like those
walls all the like walls and everything
and the roofing
tiling and all that stuff like i'm
wondering i
dude i'm willing to bet you could go 100
honestly i mean why not
all-time record 800 people in the stream
good god thank you everybody
um heck yeah dude congrats
yeah dude you've been killing it it's
both of us son
it's impressive i i every saturday i'll
like wake up at 12
p.m and i look on youtube and you're
like already showered
and probably did like a full workout in
our streaming and i'm like god damn son
oh man that's funny i'm really glad that
we're doing this together man this is
super cool this is my first like joint
3d stream i did one with casey where we
just did music but like
this this is cool oh nice dude i'm
having a great time i'm glad we did this
all right it looks like that kind of
this like pops out this little piece
here i just don't know which one that is
i got too many pieces
there it is
how's this guy sitting
i can't pronounce your name ato um
thanks for the super chat
heck yeah you appreciate the knowledge
i'm enjoying my time with peter here
and i'm really glad that you guys are
enjoying it too rock on
heck yeah um
all right peter i'm going to be i'm
going to use son
all right bam do it oh you got lighting
in there now
cool yeah yeah i threw in uh blender
just got
a fancy new sky texture node that you
can use
for the background gives you like a nice
not
super realistic but like like the
lighting is realistic the background
isn't super realistic like you would
want an hdri for clouds or whatever
but if you're just going for like
sunlight and having the blue fill from
the skylight
this thing is perfect in the world node
settings
and so i'm just using that to kind of
flip back and forth between my reference
see how we're doing looking pretty good
it looks like the lighting in this scene
i i really like because you know you
learn a lot of things by dissecting
other people's art and recreating it
they have the sunlight is really only
hitting the center of frame giving it a
nice
natural vignette um like they have
trees covering up the light from most
other parts of the scene they just have
the god rays coming in through the
center and highlighting just this little
bit so i'm going to try and do that
i'm going to block out my lighting so
that
i don't know just so that i can get a
more real
i love that style the um like the
sunlight
in the middle of like a field and then
everything is kind of like stormy on the
outside like
that look is so cool to me it's
brilliant and it's brilliant because
it's like pretty but then also the it
just helps the composition so much it
tells your eyes where to look
oh no something happened
what happened your computer did you
change your screen or something oh did
discord
dude f for chat is like popping off hard
right now
this chord freaking crapped out on me
did it really
yeah okay we'll be back
uh we'll get this back up
i still i still have you though uh do
you want to
what's that am i back i don't oh i see
you hold on let me
let me see here let me see
glenda yeah there you are there you are
there you are and your camera's loading
hey
you're back you're back sweet okay
yeah discord just pieced me out for some
reason louie son
that's what happens when you when you
gotta like
freaking tech your own your own stream
and like
do a render at the same time it's like
so much stuff
all right we're back in everybody thank
you for the moral support there
josh i see you um much appreciated
and adrian shout outs to you thank you
thank you
um so
you got peter or no okay sorry peter you
got adrian
into sculpting on blender um oh no way
yeah
heck yeah that's awesome dude adrian
that's super six how many what are you
working on i want to see it
yeah peter you're here's your your
handle at peter france on instagram
oh yeah dude i i was early enough to the
party i snagged my name on
most software or services smart
smart
all right back back to your blender
magic peter
yeah what i'm doing now is i'm jumping
on over to quicksole bridge
to grab some mega scans and i'm not
going to start placing magazines in my
scene yet
i'm just going to use them i'm going to
take this little fern here
and i'm going to place it above my scene
to block out the light
so i can get some natural shadows
covering up these areas right the
dappled look
exactly son but have you ever tried
using a noise map for that
a noise map i mean you could use a noise
map but
you don't get those the leaf leaf shapes
i got you okay well maybe is there a
card a leaf card you could use that
might be like
like an atlas you know they have those
atlases
oh maybe save on yeah i can do something
peter juice or maybe not
do you think do your thing you you had
it yeah
all right i'm gonna export that to
blender cool my scene is like the scale
of my scene is whack it's
i know mine's small i know mine's wack
too
i'll fix it later whatever dude mega
skins has this awesome bug
it's not even a bug it's just some
like flipped a wire somewhere where when
you import it to blender it puts the
bump map into the alpha
channel so you just gotta switch over to
the normal
all right oh frame or uh not frame rate
uh
aspect ratio
helps with the block out like what what
do you see in your scene
that is helpful
all right it looks like
dude this freaking this house is like
all
askew dude like it's it was built
so gently it's like pieced together i'm
trying to figure out like this
there aren't really straight lines there
are
in relation to their own little bits but
everything is kind of just
like placed in jenkily which is cool do
you think that's
part of the design or do you think
that's just a byproduct of it being
painted um it is
probably designed that way dude
definitely interesting
also your mic is frozen oh no the mic is
frozen
your your camera's frozen oh no
is it better what is he at least it's
not a smile
no it's still wait is it because i'm
using up my gpu
i have two renders going right now oh my
god
uh you're still frozen god damn it well
at least we can hear you dude
[Laughter]
oh f
f god damn it discord f for respects
dude
all right peter's gonna get his
situation back it's all good y'all at
least we
at least like wait can you can i hear
you
can you hear me yeah you're backstage
okay cool you're back soon i'm back
yeah sweet okay he's back
all right
i think i'm close enough to look at that
getting this thing ready um
thank you pretty darn close here
all right and then it looks like there's
kind of like a
cube down here because this thing looks
like it's on stilts it's so cool
like the thing i love about this piece
of art
is that like
here let me pull up the full thing
yeah the thing i love about this here is
the feeling that outside is very rainy
very wet very cold very scary
um it's a place you don't want to be you
do not want to be outside
um but inside
people are having a blast it's a good
time you have like the warm
windows it's a place where you want to
be
but it's viewed from this scary place
it's viewed from the outside which is
scary and i love like if
it feels like extra comforting to know
that there is a safe place surrounded by
a scary place and like you're inside the
safe place like that's so cool to me
that's really interesting yeah you you
have like
the contrast of color and brightness but
you also have the contrast of emotion in
the shot
yeah 100
is my video crapped out again dude it
might be
all right dang it says tell them to go
to preferences system
and deselect cpu for rendering and it
will likely fix the frozen discord
issues
oh okay preferences
system and deselect cpu for rendering
okay
princesses yeah we got some subscribers
too thanks y'all
right off
oh my goodness
all right i see you there you are okay
um okay settings
preferences uh i'm not seeing
preferences i'm seeing settings
it's preferences system
and then deselect cpu for rendering
uh jack says edit preferences system
cuda and deselect
cpu i'm not saying this here i'm
switching
edit preferences yeah there's no edit
it's just like a window
but i got user settings in blender video
oh in blender blender oh i see
i thought we were talking about discord
yeah i could do cpu let's see how that
goes
that's not too bad that's fine
all right am i still frozen oh we're
chilling heck yeah
yeah it's on whoever suggested that yeah
cool people
all right clint i think you were right
uh i'm going with the noise map
for real yeah just because i couldn't
get enough detail with the
3d model okay i got you
all right so what i'm doing here is i'm
creating a new material for this plane
as clint suggested and i'm feeding in a
noise texture
to the alpha
cool
that whole thing and then hold on
dude i thought you were frozen again i
got it i was like i thought you were
frozen
i was like dang you just thinking so my
brain was just frozen
into the matrix
[Laughter]
okay cool yeah i'm just trying to figure
out how i'm gonna do this
thing isn't it hard to think on a stream
too
dude it's so hard my brain is mush right
now
yeah cause it's like you're thinking
about so many things and it feels weird
to like stop and
think about like in detail about
something because you want to keep
talking but
it's difficult yeah that's what i
learned about like film sets is if
you're ever directing you feel like
you just have to have an answer for
something right away like somebody asks
you a question you're just like boom
answer
but in reality you can be like okay give
me a second you
walked aside and you think about it you
just give yourself a moment
and you use your clear head to come up
with a decision and then you come back
to the situation you don't have to do
everything
right in the moment that is a great
piece of advice dude
that is a great piece of advice like
yeah give me some time is totally
reasonable you don't have to have the
answer right then in there
yeah that's legit man
okay so i'm making a new texture
which i'm going to paint onto my
little light blocking thing here so i
can decide which parts of the image are
going to have light and which are not
so let's see here go back into my shader
editor
bring in the image texture lighting text
i'm going to feed this
into the alpha with the mix rgb
boom
okay so let's see if this works
so you're trying to get a dappled light
look right yeah exactly
do you get do you get like pickle bummed
when your art doesn't look good for the
first like dude of course
most of the time i spend making stuff is
like in
pain yeah
i feel the same dude i mean no it's fun
but it's also like
stressful because you know you set high
standards for yourself and
you don't live up to that expectation it
can be
very stressful yeah i know exactly what
you mean
like i i definitely feel i'm a
perfectionist
and it's tough
to try and meet your own expectations
sometimes but
yeah sometimes you just gotta chill and
like
you know figure it out keep with it
consistency yeah
all right i'm darn close um
this is feeling pretty darn close to me
this like grouping of houses here so i'm
probably
gonna start um
[Music]
what's next i'm probably gonna go
to mega scans and start building this
thing out
yeah time to hit the mega scans shout
outs to
giraffe in space and neon
for the super chat you guys are awesome
um
yeah giraffe says that we've inspired
him to be a filmmaker
and a vfx artist been following uh us
for years
and thanks to peter for getting him into
blender
that's awesome that's really nice to
hear hell yeah man so sick
clint that's looking great oh thanks
dude um here let me
get lined it up here yeah i just got to
get the
get the detail we got the block out yeah
um yo milay
what is up son melee won the like um
hope i'm saying that name right he won
he did like the anime render
the uh the render challenge montage
video
of the guy like it's like pink and blue
he's walking through with the steam
dude that was awesome so good yeah crazy
good
all those were super sweet that was an
awesome video i'm so glad you made that
oh man it it it blew me away
i want to do another one asap this year
um yeah you should do it
oh i'm gonna oh i'm gonna thank you
um all right i think it's i think it's
time to take a look
at my image here and see what i need
using uh where are you
bridge mega scans bridge oh and uh neon
elias
probably butchering that name as well i
see you um
so he's saying that streaming a discord
is generally really crappy if you have a
high load on your jeep cpu and gpu tech
tip
use google meat sounds dumb but it works
we'll use it next time interesting okay
um and then arturo with another super
chat
says peter check into the dms for the
chat's recommendation on blender
settings
uh changes and
to join us on blender nest episode
oh check it out interesting yeah go
check it out arturo send me a dm
uh instagram or or uh discord also it
works
okay so
yeah i gotta start pulling the pieces of
this puzzle here
together on the bridge
um so let's see like i need some roof
tiling
i am probably going to make these little
windows
like the frames by hand it's very simple
um
it looks like i need some wooden like
tatami
style japanese style kind of
pieces of wood here um
some pipes and some vents and like it's
really like a roof
and then i guess if i really had to like
get detailed with this let me pull up
this guy here full screen
so i'm gonna build this out um i'm gonna
start
pulling pieces here um like this
really gross wood it's all about this
gross wood right here that's awesome
um and the roof tiling and stuff
while i do that uh peter i'll be on
beyond you
all right sounds good man what you
working on
still trying to get the lighting worked
in yeah yeah dude
these freaking nodes are confusing me
i'm trying to
so i got looks super janky right now but
i got
this little plane up here that should
have a little
uh transparent bit in the middle of it
to let the sun come through
but my coffeed out brain is like
having a hard time understanding my own
nodes which is just like
the story of my life understanding my
own nodes
yeah i've definitely been there yeah
take a second no
no pressure and uh
heck yeah figure out what that's going
to mix that in the fact oh
what
dude color amps all dude
heck
okay i'm just gonna wait what
what's going on oh yes
i got it
there we freaking go all right
it was inverted now we're talking yeah i
just had to invert it
it's so funny man everyone's like in the
chat they're like inverted
i was trying
all right cool let's look at the
reference again see how we're doing
big chilling okay i'm gonna extend that
so it covers our background as well
all right maybe move it up a bit i just
ripped my pants
you just ripped your pants that dang it
it's ripped the hole in my pants
are you serious yeah how'd you even do
that i just handled my back pocket
freaking easy grip of
zeus right there
oh son oh that's looking good hey that's
looking nice
yeah thanks man yeah
you were right about that noise map it
definitely made it a lot simpler cool
cool all right i think now it is time to
move on to
detail i'm gonna do this cliff in the
back first and i think the way i'm going
to do that
is with some good old-fashioned mega
scans
that's where i'm at
dude you hear they got they came out
with some like crazy new cliffs and
stuff
yeah that's what i'm using baby heck
yeah
oh new money ground
volcanologist lab fancy
do you ever build like an asset layout
or do you just drag stuff in your scene
and like forget about it and just move
it
what do you mean by asset layout like
where you'll like
you'll basically go into um
you basically like go into a scene and
you'll have a separate project or a
separate window
or like off to the side all of your
assets that you pulled in from bridge
like
laid out like a plant and then a wooden
beam and then everything it's like so
you can see the toys you're playing with
and then you duplicate
that's really smart i don't do that and
i definitely
am going to start doing that because
it's a really good idea i i
never really do that but i was watching
um
joe garth's uh unreal engine tutorial
on learn squared and he does that where
he like lays this stuff out to see what
he's looking at
that's clever yeah oftentimes i'll like
especially in unreal i'll be like
populating a scene with stuff
and then i just start duplicating things
and then i forget about this one asset
that's in this like one little spot and
then it's just like a million of one
asset
and none of that other one so that
definitely would be helpful
yeah to see like what you have dude it'd
be so sick to have like
i got a 3d palette we're like
you can have like an ipad with all your
assets on it you just swipe them up into
your scene
whoa dude that's the future right there
i'd be so sick
oh my god i freaking tried uh laying out
a scene in unreal with vr the other day
it was
amazing oh for real you just like put on
your vr headset
and then as opposed to like playing the
game you just go into the editor
and you can like put in uh assets with
your controllers and stuff and it's so
much easier than doing it in a 2d view
because you actually have
a 3d perspective of the scene hello i'd
like to introduce the stream
to my lovely girlfriend kaylee
[Laughter]
who's being shy hello
this is kaylee she just brought me a
butterfly
this is the sweetest thing it is dead
where did you find this
on the sidewalk oh my goodness it's
beautiful that's legit dude oh
okay bye-bye thank you
what a nice gift dude it's so nice
[Laughter]
it's hilarious wow that is beautiful
love you that's special dude
especially super special dude kaylee's
the best
oh man dude i feel like there's so much
more work to do
i know i'm just freaking looking at mega
skins how much time do we have
whenever there's no time limit just go
you know oh cool
until it's chill until we're like i
can't i can't do this anymore
[Laughter]
uh josh thanks for the super chat
madelina thank you
um he says nice smoothie tutorial
is that a reference
yeah kaylee made a smoothie tutorial
it's it's like a blender tutorial but
it's like an actual blender got you got
you
the people like your blender tutorial
[Laughter]
you gotta say thanks
and then madeline is tall oh
that's awesome dude shout outs that's
great
oh man all right um
so thanks for entertaining a tired 10
hour till deadline architecture student
keep up the good work uh we got you we
got you
good luck on your project son yeah
what tablet am i using i'm using a a
wacom intuos
pro 4 the medium-sized one it's the best
i love it
why'd you start using a wacom um because
i figured if like
if i'm gonna be doing this for the rest
of my life i want to save
my wrist and i heard that this was like
healthier
or more ergonomic that's probably a
really good idea
and then other than that um
i don't know for drawing and stuff if i
want to do drawings it's just easier to
draw
totally yeah that's cool i should
probably get one of those don't we have
like a bunch of those in the studio
yeah yeah definitely nice
all right so what i do when i'm in
bridge here is i actually like favorite
it all favorite stuff
um oh cool yeah and then i need some
roof
tiles so i'm just gonna hook up a roof
and see what they got okay this is cool
um
i think tech technically
the roofing would be oh
i like that that's nice
ishan what is going on what what on
earth is going on you have
um peter and myself i'm in cinema 4d
making some ghibli art and then you got
um
you got peter in blender hey hey making
some more ghibli art
represent yeah so we're making some fun
stuff cinema 4d
and blender unite um
[Music]
making some cool art man yeah going to
town
heck yeah right now i'm gathering assets
to build this to build my scene out and
peter what are you doing
i'm too freaking nose dude i'm trying to
okay so i got
i got my first mega scan in baby's first
mega scan
and uh i realized there needs to be a
little light hitting this thing so i'm
gonna try and go back into my
dreaded light map that is
not entirely working and screw it i'm
just going to freaking cut a piece out
of it
all right so what i'm trying to do here
is i'm trying to get some light hitting
this little cliff right here
shout out to cliff shout out to the
cliff
so maybe like right there let's just
hide
those faces no let's hide
those faces no let's hide those faces
now
with those how about
god where the heck is this coming from
you're like what are you looking for
yeah i'm trying to figure out where the
light's coming from
your lights is your light below your
plane dude in this direction
no no no no it's above
what the heck y'all oh it's probably not
showing because it's only
i'm not actually deleting the vertices
troubleshooting
is a thing it happens to everybody no
matter
how good you are
there you go oh there we go now we're
now we're cooking
hey so i think it's right here
boom baby that looks awful but at least
now i know where to paint
dang dude this is freaking hard man this
is just gonna take hours to find the
right textures in this crap dude
oh man i gotta get these roof tiles
correct
there we go
okay sweet
there's probably such a better way to do
this but i'm kind of locked into this
now
and i'm just going to say whatever
yeah i'm trying to decide whether should
i do these roof tiles
one by one and like clone them
or if i should just do
[Music]
maybe for them it's only one section
maybe i should just do it like all
as 3d objects that would be that'd be
dumb
roof tile
nice you're like painting in the light
oh yeah
okay i think that should work yeah there
we go
okay now we're talking
that's super cool on the fire thanks
dude
yeah it's definitely like maybe the
worst way i could do this but it's
working well enough that i'm not going
to stop
i hear you for sure
that's like all of capitalism
yeah like it's going
i'll just keep going i guess
dang i need like metal like corrugated
metal
it's looking nice dude i can see it like
oh my wait
is that rock texture back there thanks
man yeah it's just a little mega skin
it's baby's first mega scan that looks
so good
thanks yeah okay i think we got the
lighting
also what am i doing i could just be
adding lights to my scene i could just
freaking throw in like a point light
here and a point light there why am i
messing with
a freaking sun whatever
okay
cool all right it is time to throw in
some mega scans
more mega skins yeah
actually sorry what were we gonna say
i'll just say
nothing important i'm just browsing mega
scans
you should just do a stream one on
saturday just like browsing mega scans
you don't even make anything you just
look through and you're like
oh that's nice i'll save that
be the biggest commercial
honest oh my god if you could get that
sweet sweet epic games
quicksole uh sponsorship that'd be sick
yeah that'd be sick yeah these guys are
great
okay i got some like roof tiling
business uh i got some wooden beams
um pipes i'll do later
let's try and get
some wood paneling i'm still staying on
you
you're you're uh nice you're doing cool
stuff over there
sweet yeah i um this is one of the 3d
scans
of plants i did let's see oh i wish i
could use my gpu
dude oh my god but yeah it works
like surprisingly well
and this was just for from like walking
around this plant for five minutes
and that is that on your phone or is
that on dslr
yeah this was dslr it was just like a
gloomy day san francisco i was walking
around
you get some pretty damn good detailed
plants that's
amazing in my opinion like like mega
scans are great for populating a
background
and for like using an unreal and stuff
but if you want the really high
detail plants mega scans doesn't really
have much of that
um i generally like to use 3d scans for
that
polygon stuff is nuts dude the polygon
stuff is amazing
yeah they have the best like potted
plants
yeah they're like photo real it's nuts
cool so i'm gonna bring in another one
of those little 3d scans i did
dude just building out my own like 3d
scan library has been so nice
i've been putting stuff up on my patreon
too it's just
i don't know there's something rewarding
about having an asset
library that you made yourself you know
100 man
yeah um like with those imperfections
like your your surface imperfections
yeah those are freaking awesome
it's so much fun because then you just
make the stuff you always use you know
and then if you don't use your own stuff
then you know it's like oh crap i should
probably do a better job
yeah totally
oh boy blender's chucking trying to
import this 3d scan
lots of geometry do you have lods with
your stuff
no i should or i i do have like a high
quality and a low
low poly version um
but uh not as much as i should let's see
where's this freaking there's this other
plant i'm trying to get where the heck
is it
oh here we go plant 03 maybe
that's it
no no four
plant 04 that's the one
all right i got my first roof tile in
here
go ahead again
i went with a a 2k
texture because you know basically
i think we were actually talking about
this uh the other day at work
um yeah like what i try and do
is import like the the 2k textures the
low res textures
and that way i'll keep my computer alive
you know because especially if i have a
lot of stuff
i'll just do low res textures until i
look at the final and i see oh i need to
update these textures
here here and here and then those will
be 4k or 8k
when they're closer to camera and then
it's okay my scene is like optimized
yeah that's really smart yeah because
you can always switch it out later but
if you have a bunch of like
8k 4k stuff in your scene it's just
going to be a
[ __ ] and a half to switch it all out
yeah most definitely
so i got this roof tile here um
it's not bad at all usually i go in here
i change this to glossy
and octane that just has a nicer shine
to it
i can come in here and like tweak this a
little bit more
maybe the roughness
i can i already has a color correction
node on it i can crank the contrast
maybe and like
have certain parts be more reflective
more specular
or even do it with a gradient maybe
i'm gonna pee real quick yeah go for it
all right so yeah i'm gonna try and
populate this roof tile across the top
up here
and basically i'll need to like
stretch this out you can see how it's
like a very
intense shape here so
maybe what we'll do
uh silver gaming this week's challenge
will be announced at the end of the
stream
along with the winners of this week's
challenge which was
color
all right let's just try and get this
looking nice so i want to stretch it
not too crazy though because i don't
want it to be like really bad looking
it is going to be a distance away so i
think what i'll do
is take this stuff and i want to
clone it so i'm going to hold alt throw
in a cloner
i can pause my renderer and just make
sure you guys are saving constantly
and i just want to kind of bring these
guys it looks like they're
snugged up onto each other like this
and they're closed in
like that
open them up just a little bit and they
kind of clamp on to each other like that
and then from here you can obviously
like really
push how many
you're duplicating i always set my
instance mode to multi-instance
that way you can duplicate a bunch of
stuff a lot
a whole lot of times without really
taking down
your performance so we'll go to town on
this
i know it's not quite the same roof but
it'll do the trick
so let's see what up son
maybe we rotate these guys around
or we can mess with the
transform there we go yeah flip them
this way maybe
yeah 180.
yeah the tiles are laying on each other
basically
something like that and then you can use
you can actually keep rotating
here so they all kind of like sit up
just a little bit
don't worry about peter he's taking a
small break he'll be back in a second no
worries
and then let's take these tiles
and see if we can't like
position them up like this but also mess
with the transform
can we step the transform so i want to
be able to
let's see per step
should be able to get these to like
stack a little bit
oh he's trying to talk to me peter i
can't hear you you got to call me again
on my phone
let me call this something it's a very
complicated technical situation we got
going
thanks y'all
all right i see you peter
hey hey yo what's up son there we go
all right we're back we're good
callus uh kalupsi thanks for joining
catch you later man
peace step deformer yeah step deformer
is totally the way to do it so i'm gonna
have my cloner selected
and let's do a uh
where's my deformers at boom here we go
i want a b
where are you mr step there you are step
deformer but we don't want to do it
through
scale we want to do it through y
position
we don't want to go from left to right
we want to go from front to back
so i think that would be in the
coordinates of this thing maybe rotate
it around how's this going to work
no
[Music]
um
maybe
experimenting how want to rotate it
around
the step modifier is going from left to
right i want it to go
from front to back
step effector instead there's different
ones
let's see
i've never even used this i don't know
what this is now that is the step
effector
mograph
vector zap that's what i have literally
what i have
i just need to change this i need to
rotate this around somehow
all right um
cloner changes what do you think
and i don't know
all right well peter while i
troubleshoot this oh going to you son
heck yeah do it
uh let me see if i can get your thing
back up here
where are you i should be streaming
watch it
i'm it's trying to connect to your
capture here
uh well it should be working
[Music]
where are you at yeah i'm not seeing
see you but i don't see your blender
discord is streaming all right let me
work it i'm going to hang up and i'm
going to call you back all right
sounds good
weird
can you stop sharing your screen and
then share again yeah
give that a shot there you go
there we go i think we're good now
awesome
then we'll hit you back all right we're
we're in we're watching you
hell yeah okay so i got some of my 3d
scans in here i'm kind of just lining
them up
to where they are in the scene here
getting some rough
for this like foreground plant stuff i
want to have some high detail
scan action going on
get some of that nice detail
just lining that up getting that to look
all pretty
big chilling
yeah if if you've never experimented
with 3d scanning before
i highly recommend it it is very fun
and it's kind of addicting i just find
myself
like going out with my dslr when i lived
in san francisco i did this a bunch you
just go out with a camera
you walk around like a forest path or a
little park
you see something and you just look like
a total doofus taking a million pictures
like rotating around it like to
everybody else you probably look like
the world's
worst photographer totally
but uh no it's super fun you get a ton
of great stuff
and then you can just take it into
reality capture
process it and then just throw it into
your scene willy nilly it's
wonderful i i really enjoy it
yeah i messed with the with photo scans
on that parallel dimensions
render i did of myself oh nice cliff
came over and helped uh
help scan me oh yeah that was that model
was you right yeah
um nice and it made me really want to do
more of it it's like super
fun it's so fun and just the amount of
detail you get is absolutely nuts
yo roomie we gotta chill it out chill it
out with the uh
with the spam in here dude you don't get
you gonna get the boot if you ain't
careful son
don't worry i got my problem solved
appreciate it i'm gonna duplicate this
and
take out this tree nonsense
god like clint are you seeing this yes
detail right here yeah it's ridiculous
dang god dang that's your skin
that's so cool it's so easy too it's
it's like dumb are you using would say
reality capture
for that stuff yeah reality capture is
the fastest one i've found
nice runs on your gpu i don't know they
got some kind of algorithm making it
fast
that's awesome yeah i mean you know it's
it's not like
lightning fast you still gotta wait like
it's probably like 30 minutes total per
scan but that's not nearly as bad as
other software
dude this this image is gonna take me
forever what
no dude you gotta you gotta just do
those broad strokes you know get those
crappy materials in there and then add
detail if you need to
yeah you're right i think i need to get
my windows going and like the lighting
and stuff
right now maybe
i'm just replacing this little block out
with the real shrub
let's see here
hmm
you sound like a minecraft villager
trying to figure out the best way to do
these like
little screen windows i think i need to
make like
a block of one and then i'll like
duplicate it
across that's really a good idea yeah
dude your scene is looking nice dude
thanks man yeah i'm jealous i'm pretty
happy with how it's going
god i wish there were mega scans had
trees dude
i know only they had trees seriously
that's what we need
and eddie says you need god rays god
raised i agree i think that's going to
be like a last step
yeah to get those you know i might even
do those in comp
actually no no no no i can't do that in
comp it would look way worse
but let's see i'm going to
duplicate my little shrub and i'm going
to make a super
low poly version of that to populate my
background with because we got
tons of shrubbery back here and i want
to be able to just copy and paste this
without having my computer
hate me
so i'm going to put a little decimate
modifier on there bring the geometry
down a bit
maybe i'll even solo this go into
material preview
and i'm going to take out
i'm gonna take out the rest of this
ground here so we're just
left with the shrub
how often do you create scenes that like
chug your computer hard
i mean honestly it's it's so depends you
know sometimes i'll have
scenes that i feel are really complex
and my computer doesn't bat an eye and
then sometimes i have scenes
that are like not that complex my
computer's like
yeah so i don't know um but recently for
my short film i've been doing a lot of
like
city renders um like full cg city and my
computer is just like
no thank you it takes a while so i've
had to get really
diligent about creating folders
of like background elements and then a
subfolder of like
buildings people objects and stuff like
that and then i can just
toggle those on and off for specific
uh use cases you know i pretty much i'll
like block out the scene with all the
props and everything and then
the last step once i am ready to hit
render i've done all the animating and
stuff is to turn back on
all that uh like uh
i don't know the render heavy stuff yeah
yeah that makes total sense
cool so i got my shrub isolated here
and i'm going to throw another decimate
modifier on
get this to be real low poly so i can
just smack the background with it
smack that background
i'm actually going to i got all these
little bits and bobs that i don't need
so i'm going to select the main
area ctrl l to select everything linked
to it
invert my selection with ctrl i oh i got
to turn on screencast keys what am i
doing
so people can see oh that's a thing
yeah dude it's great it's a plug-in for
blender where you just
enable it and then it shows which keys
you're hitting dude i gotta get that for
c4d
that's nice it's super nice i bet they
have
an equivalent probably yeah
where are you screencast keys
there we go
not seeing it
you're usually able to see it on your
side oh it's because i'm using 2.9 it's
not
i don't have the right version installed
that's all right
okay let's populate that background yeah
let's do
oh
uh i wish you could do like dual monitor
streams
that'd be awesome yeah maybe you can i
just don't know about it
yeah it would also be tough for like
people watching in 16x9 you know
very yeah
all right i got my little scaffolding
thing going here
um thank you let's see it so basically i
just
created this little thing in a separate
project i'm always hopping in a new
projects to like make stuff small
and then i'll i'll like copy it into
like the big one
um that's clover so it's just a paper
window right here
and then you could just take this
probably group all these things
and you gotta switch over so then oh i
did
oh i'm delayed there you go sorry
he scared me um i'll throw a bevel in
there
that way like i'm beveling everything at
once and i'll just give it like
subdivision of three nice point too but
it looks like it's chunking right there
but you probably won't be able to see
that from so far away
i think that's totally fine and we can
turn on all of our bevels
i don't need to yeah it i'll just drag
it in
i think my biggest thing right now is to
like actually hollow out these buildings
and get the lighting going
totally how are you going to haul them
out um i'm
probably the easiest way is probably
just to inset and extrude
i think would be the easiest way nice
yeah i think i will do that
all right so yeah grab this face and
i'll do m
w to inset and then d will push it back
and like technically there's like a
cut so we can hit kl hold shift
we'll go right in the middle boom we can
take that move it
go to edge mode ul for loop selection
w and then we'll move this over
and then we can grab this face and just
push it back even further because
technically like it goes around the
corner
if you look at this image here like
there's like a little
it goes around the corner there dude
that's looking great
i mean i barely have anything dude
let's see
get this paper window popping off yeah
it's all about getting those
large-scale things placed first
totally
and rename your stuff that way
god that's the best piece of advice that
i never follow
yeah because things get out of hand like
it gets crazy
all right and then let's see if i can
just clone this
all the way across
a linear cloner and
looks like it's on the z-axis
the left and we might be able to get
away with four
copies and just kind of crunch it maybe
a little bit
maybe it's three with like
one of them slid in or something
yeah push it back a little bit like that
and then maybe we go in here and
actually like mess with
the actual shape of this thing oh come
on
what the heck oh my god
am i freezing i might be freezing all
right i'm switching to you
just crashed all right oh no no
take the reins peter
all right so
yeah i've started going through and
adding some plants i'm pretty much just
taking this plant 3d scan i have and
duplicating it all over the place
i'm doing like i find that 3d scans are
really nice for adding density because
it's like a solid
object whereas the mega scans are just
like there's lots of transparency
and those are nice for once you have the
density you want
foliage wide
then adding those on top to give it the
nice detail because i mean obviously
these 3d scans are just like
kind of garbage geometry especially in
the back here it's just like
looks like hot nothing so uh
once uh once we have the density figured
out i'm going to go in and throw in some
mega scans but yeah right now i'm just
throwing
these plants all over the place and i'm
pretty happy with how it's looking so
far
looking sick man thanks dude
and there's just like so much so much
detail to get hung up on here
i know it's crazy
all right a little tip for my blender
users uh if you have
an object that you're duplicating a
bunch around your scene
you're going to want to do alt d instead
of shift d because shift d
duplicates the object and makes it its
own object but
but alt d just makes a new instance of
the same
object so it only loads one of those
objects
into your memory when you're rendering
and uh when you're in the 3d viewport so
you're not like
loading a ton of geometry into your
render that like
might max out your gpu you're just uh
basically using the same object a bunch
of times instead of
a bunch of individual objects that are
the same thing the only downside
it's really nice the only downside
though is that
if you want to edit the object you are
basically editing all the objects
so you have to go to object
relations and make single user object
and data and then you can edit that one
object as its own object
but it's a great great little tip for
keeping your scenes clean and organized
nice
well you know looking at these scenes
something i'm realizing is that
they're very careful about where they
put detail you know in this background
here there's like almost no detail it's
just like a few
brush strokes whereas down here there's
tons of little
pins and needles of flowers and
everything and i think that's
purposeful to draw your eye away from
the background
and more towards the focus of the scene
that's kind of a challenge in 3d because
you know if you just have nothing back
there it's
it's the realistic render so it's gonna
look like you have nothing back there
but if you have too much back there then
it's gonna be distracting so i think
i might have to
might have to just bring this into
photoshop after after effects and
do a little smudging and painting on top
of the image
that'd be cool yeah i've never really
done that before but
like me neither i feel like it could be
actually really really sick
to be able to do something like that
especially with these
totally people was doing that when he
was over at corridor i know
he's like the master of that stuff yeah
oh man this is awesome i am
having a good time i think i think my
render is going to take me like
two streams to be able to do this oh no
dude you can do it i believe in you all
right i'm trying
to get those bare bones yeah
man we both bite off more than we can
chew
like all why do we always do that
because it kind of works yeah isn't it
sick to be like
watch this like check this out yeah it's
like in smash
when you're like uh
what was dean saying last night he was
like
when in smash you say watch this and
then you actually do something yeah
like that's the best feeling it's it's
just the greatest feeling but that's
what that's what got me killed in the
in that first tournament when um sam
killed himself
and i was like in my head i was like
wouldn't this be sick and i jumped off
and killed myself in a tournament and i
was like dude never again
oh no yeah so dumb
never again
all right i promise i'll have like
a lot done when we come back to my
screen
awesome
cool i'm just this is just like foliage
city over here that's awesome so dense
super cool
it's really nice like having multiple
views
was something i learned early on that
helps
so much is you like have your camera
view and then you don't do like
anything in your camera view unless you
need to do it from the front on
perspective you just have like your
separate navigation view
you know where you're moving around and
doing all your work and then you can see
what's going to be in your final image
at the same time that's a really
really good point and i love your layout
i think your layout is really nice
thanks yeah yeah it's definitely helpful
for staying organized
yeah that's basically the um in octane
you can
uncheck the check camera option which is
so confusing
um wait what does that mean um it
basically is like what you have
where you have a locked camera and you
can see your edits in the camera
perspective oh gotcha yeah
nice yeah that's super helpful
yeah octane's great has a real a lot of
really nice features
i've been thinking about playing around
with it
it's fun yeah it's a good time all right
let's see how this is looking
looks jank
dude i have like i'm just like hacking
through
all of these polygons same
also the scale of my scene is so whack
like the
the foreground is like tiny and the
background is huge
that's great
you know what i should probably fix that
but
whatever
i'm looking at mine right now and i'm
like what is what is this
i don't think it matters though at least
for what i'm doing right now
i'm gonna start throwing in some more
lights so i can dial this in a little
bit further
looking real nice man thanks dude
all right most i'm almost ready to
switch back over and show you
it's wait can't wait how far i've come
gotta have my lights at like five
gazillion percent
yeah you have to blast your lights out
like crazy yeah
um let's do
was the last time you like sat down
constantly
unbroken to like work on something like
this
dude just freaking my short film's been
taking ages i'm so ready to be done with
it oh man
it's super exciting too though like
you're close right
yeah pretty close um very happy with how
it's turning out
just trying to freaking get to the
finish line here
yeah your cg shots on that are
ridiculous man they look so
good thanks man oh yeah
yeah it's a a lot of like pre-planning
for the vfx has helped a ton
i uh you know i 3d scanned my actor
well in advance and i've just had that
as as i've been going so anytime i like
have an extra shot i just want to get
off hand yeah you know i just
can do it you know as long as it's
relatively obscured and you throw some
camera shake in there
just great having a 3d model of your
actor that's awesome
all right so this is where this is where
i'm at right now i got
my like windows in here which is
definitely taking it to the next level
um compared to the actual reference you
know this is kind of like what it's
looking at
here and i just realized oh there's like
a wood piece here
that's why they don't have the
oh nice that looks great let me just add
that on as an extra piece
yeah it's just different like planes and
boards and
keep laying that stuff down there's like
extra details everywhere oh it can get
very daunting looking at these details
seriously
oh boy
all right so
let's see let's maybe add this
this wood plane in
that's basically just going to be a cube
scaled down and like positioned up and
i'll get to the texturing stuff
do you text her like as you go or do you
text her at the end or like how do you
text her peter
you know i i usually i try to texture at
the end
but usually what ends up happening is
i'll lose steam
and i i like throw coals in the train
engine by like
making something that looks nice yeah
you know and so
i'm like i get to a certain point i'm
like this sucks and so i'll like throw a
texture on something and i'm like oh
that looks nice
and then i'm ready to keep going i
that's that is exactly what i do
that's hilarious
let me just nice to encourage yourself
once in a while yeah absolutely and
that's exactly what we do right now
because i'm going to get some lights
going in these scenes here um
[Music]
probably just get some like soft
lights some make some octane lights here
oh is it crashing dude i think i think
it's crashing
oh no no clint all right
back to you peter
cool all right
sweet yeah i'm just placing my lights
dude lighting is so freaking important
in a render oh yeah like mixer breaks it
oh yeah i love that soft look that you
got it's like almost
like it's in a cave system or something
yeah i i think a lot of what's making
this look nice is that they have this
volumetric
light you know the blue light back here
so maybe i'll
i'll play with that real quick it's
gonna freaking
kill my computer but here goes
oh boy big cube
that to viewport display wire
let's add a little material
make it volumetric
dude volumetrics for me is like
is my uh inspiration boost
like i'll throw a volume some like fog
in there and i'm like all right it's
cool it's cool like i still got it
it yeah it really helps bringing life to
it i
i was playing have you played half-life
alex
no i really want to dude it's
it's the most fun i've had playing a
video game ever it's
an amazing experience that's awesome and
yeah uh they just released a commentary
version so you can go through and like
their little headphone objects that you
can put up pick up and put on
oh cool so you can like hear how they
made it yeah
and they were talking about volumetrics
and it was such a challenge for them to
get it to render
in vr because you know you run during
two games at the same time in vr one for
each eye
and so it's like super taxing on the
system and it was like nearly impossible
for them to get
volumetric lighting working wow but once
they did it it just like made their
scenes feel so much more
tactile and alive and playing back
through the game it's so true like
all the moodiness in those scenes are
like a direct result of
that volumetric lighting yeah it's all
about the fog man it looks just looks so
good
and this is looking jank dude
i think i got something oh that's
something
it's a very soft light in this scene
um
all right starting to look all right
okay yeah the fog definitely helped a
lot just with composition
ah but i'm getting my freaking light is
casting
i just move my light up higher
i want to switch my g i'm gonna switch
to my gpu i'm gonna see if it breaks it
uh-oh we'll find out my headphones are
uh
i have to switch oh no yeah i have to
switch uh
headphones um i'm gonna leave this call
going
let me just run and grab my bone phones
um sounds good
keep it up man keep uh all right keep
doing cool stuff i'll be back in like
two seconds
heck yeah
all right so
we got our fog going right here but once
it renders in a little bit you'll see
that let's change that to 100.
so once this
loads in you'll see that i have a light
right here that's kind of casting light
right into the fog i'm pointing at my
screen you can't see that
but we're getting like you can see where
the light starts and that's going to
look
jank in the final render so i just gotta
just gotta take this light
and move it up a little bit fix that
let's see here where's that thing there
she is
just move that back turn it up
that should fix the problem dude both of
my headphones are
dead oh no no not good
hopefully when these die i can grab the
other ones that i'm charging now
totally oh
baby
okay we got something like semi-usable
now
semi emphasis on the semi
uh oh oh your discord here goes
yep back to cpu
that's hilarious
i'm trying to get my colors right here
trying to match these colors
the saturated white can probably come
down
hmm oh nice clint
looking good yeah i think i gotta get
like
this color temperature correct it's a
little like white still
i think could be in a few different
things but
maybe it just needs to go a bit more
towards that orange maybe it's a little
bright still
yeah i feel like that blue could go more
towards purple
more okay yeah that's good to know
whoa way too much
oh dude i oh my god i scanned like a
dude i crashed a cobblestone no
all right back to you damn i scanned
this cobblestone wall one time
i think i'm just gonna use that for
these little uh
little thingy thingies that works yeah
not bad okay let's bring that in
are you starting to chug yet um no
my scene or what yeah no i don't have
enough stuff in my scene to chug yet i'm
still like
working on the block outs of all this
stuff nice
yeah i mean your scene is more like
like the block out it's probably going
to take more time because it's mostly
those blocks and not much like foliage
or anything like that yeah
where's that cobblestone wall
there she is
all right we got 826 people up in here
right now still
heck yeah it's popping off man we're
making ghibli stuff
i'm using uh i'm using c4d peter's using
blender
and we're both making some different
scenes yeah it's a good time
having a dang good time my dude yeah
ah how about that why is this
transparent
the heck dude maybe it's still loading
maybe it's like chugging super hard
i don't know
i'm using the viewport display color
dude ren is here
he finally he's here
ren you are a moderator now
[Laughter]
heck yeah what's up son
ren's a mod yeah dude
he's like i am
[Laughter]
that's great
dude ran it's good to have you here i
wish you were on the stream with us i
know seriously it'd be crazy i'd have to
get a third window like it'd be even
dude we should do that
yeah 100 dude that would be amazing we
should get like five people and hire
somebody to
switch between us dude
that'd be great oh you died again peter
damn it
i wasn't even using my gpu dude is we're
using all the computer juice right now
okay that's i'm switching to my gpu if
i'm gonna die without my gpu then i'm
gonna die with it
let me try switching the stream
to
um stream settings can i change stream
settings mid-stream i don't know
i don't think so
dang oh my god i have a perfect thing
wait what
oh my god i literally took a different
photo scan
of a fire pit in my backyard yeah this
one's on my patreon and it's like
the exact shape i need it's perfect
that's amazing that's like you can come
across like the perfect the perfect
asset
the perfect asset dude my computer's
like blowing up
oh no
why can't i render this dude
screw it i'm just keep building i'll
just keep building
oh it was transparent because i have
freaking
the transparent mode turned on dude
that's your answer
um ren says he wants to see your
workflow using your uh your lidar photo
scans
oh dude i mean
me too i haven't done anything with that
yet
the potential for that is crazy though
honestly maybe i'll make a
tutorial for that i mean it's i don't
even know if that warrants the tutorial
it's like the easiest thing in the world
i mean dude that'd be cool like a full
the full workflow
yeah maybe definitely cleaning it up
would be nice to know
but yeah for those of you who don't know
if you have an iphone 12
uh pro maybe
i'm not sure exactly which one it is
it's the one with lidar scanning
you can use the lidar scanner to
basically do a real-time
um like photogrammetry like 3d scanning
it's amazing you use this app called
polycam
and you just like walk around an
environment with your phone and it scans
it in real time it's crazy that's so
cool
i can't wait to use it for anything i
haven't
used it for anything yet but i'm very
excited
all right looks like our texture's a bit
jank
dude my headphones died again
what the heck dude
what the heck
can you hear me oh
clint's headphones died
that's tragic
rip
dude all my headphones are dead
oh no all
can you hear me this is tragic
i can't hear you wow
let me see if i can borrow some
headphones i'll be back peter keep doing
your thing dude you're rocking it you're
crushing this right now
i'll be back
all right oh man these cobblestone walls
are the little fire pit asset
it's on my patreon if you want to snag
that
it's going to work so well
yeah yeah
and pull this 3d scan down a bit
there we go
maybe this one as well see the end of
that cobblestone
there we go
let's see how we're looking here
all right nice i am very happy with how
this is looking so far
heck yeah
definitely have a lot of work to do but
where the heck is my ground son
all right peter can you huh can you hear
me i can hear you clint
all right i just have you on
speakerphone okay cool
hopefully you'll be quiet enough so that
you're not picked up on the mic
yeah why the heck is my ground all the
way down there
what the heck happened
lots of lots of freaking tech
to to work when you're doing a dual
stream like this like
definitely a good learning experience
for me the next one will be
even better this one's awesome by the
way like
i don't think it's lacking really much
of anything
what the [ __ ]
okay this is jank something happened i
gotta re-import my
i think you're frozen again
i'm frozen i think so damn it
i just want to use my gpu all right so
i'm
i'm basically here trying to get these
windows popping off um
let's see if i can't extrude inner here
or maybe even spawn
a what do we want to grab maybe we'll
spawn i'll hold control
and bless you
if you hold ctrl it'll actually spawn
like
an object onto the area where uh
the object you have selected is selected
so you can see how i made this cube
basically right on this little hut
area right here
all right peter you're back thank you
i'm just making a little window sill
here i'm still like
still blocking out all this stuff man it
just takes forever with all this
detail and geometry
and i'm hitting n on my keyboard n
and then you can see a b c and d are my
different shading modes
so i was in n a which was really hard to
see things
because it's accounting for the light so
i'm hitting n b that'll bring up my
wireframe mode but
it still has the light nc
takes all the lighting out and nd is all
the lighting out with wireframe on
and uh
josh thanks for the super chat dude what
do you mean wren uses blender
ever installed blander he um
he told me he's really ashamed about it
and i said there's nothing to be ashamed
of
i feel like like when jenna goes to
sleep
he'll like sneak into the computer room
and start using blender
oh for real yeah dang dude
that's crazy like yeah he has a lot of
shame
surrounding it but uh you know i tell
him there's nothing to worry about
he said hey don't out me dude
dude rent it's cool man like you can you
can ask for help with this stuff
literally
all right i got my window so going my
ground plane got all jacked up son
dude everything's all jacked up for me
just trying to freaking make a
windowsill
i'm starving too oh my god
i'm pretty hungry too
all right peter if you can get something
that you are proud of at the end of this
then we can call it
because i think you're going to get
there first uh
i don't know man i believe in you i'm
working i'm i'm
i'm going hard maybe i'll do the low
poly version
oh that'd be cool
okay i think i got my ground plane like
relatively fixed
here it's like fine i guess
okay cool all right what to do next
should probably start working on this
grass
yeah grass here i'm gonna switch to okay
i just got this plug-in called graswald
for blender i've never used it
but i've heard it's awesome so let's see
here
let's install that
so how like where do you find your
blender plugins
there's a website called blender market
and it just has
everything you'd ever want it's
wonderful it has a bunch of
models and plugins and even tutorials
and stuff like that
it's great nice
what am i even looking for oh yeah
under let's see here
grass world was probably on my
there we go
dandy floss yo thanks for the super chat
got you with the content man
yeah it's super fun if you guys like
this if you like doing these uh
these group streams let me know um
because we'll do more of them i'd love
to have
our boy ren on eventually maybe see if
ian is down to come on we can do a
freaking superstretch
dude i'd love to do another one of these
this is super fun
okay let's see if i can figure out how
to use this plugin real time on the
stream
create new settings okay dude that's
always the most stressful
oh that's a lot of plants
there is chugging
station oh my god dude there's a
freaking balcony i forgot there's a
balcony on this thing
oh man
yo thanks for the super chat man um yeah
the deep fake video comes out tomorrow
it's gonna be nuts
on corridor um we all work super hard on
it to bring
uh mr luke skywalker back to life
heck yeah dude i'm so excited for that
to come out i know
i know it was a really really cool
experience um niko's just so good with
all the deep fake stuff and he like
taught us a lot
helped us um you know guide us through
the whole process and
we filmed we had to like film re-film it
you guys will see you'll see
it was a very enlightening experience
definitely
all right so i'm just going through i'm
painting where i want the grass to be
crosswald seems pretty sweet so far
pretty easy to use
still uses a particle system but i think
it just does a lot of work for you of
changing the settings in there and i
don't know maybe it does some custom
stuff too let's find out
what's the longest time you've ever
spent on a shot peter
probably when i was working on that
spider-man short film back in the day
i was just like sleeping at corridor
pulling all-nighters left and right
like spending way too much time on each
shot i just like wanted to die
but it was worth it man like the passion
that's nice to hear i'm glad
what about you the longest i spent on a
shot was definitely
like a month for the parallel dimensions
one
damn yeah dude that one was awesome it's
a great looking shot
thanks movie quality i never i've never
spent that long on a shot before
and like it was really cool to be able
to do that
and like put how to feel
yeah that's super sweet wait can you
still hear me yeah i can hear on the
phone okay do it can i hear you on
stream
okay great yeah that must have been fun
i want to participate in the next one
dude you should man it's uh i learned so
much while doing it too
heck yeah okay i think this should work
right
okay now my headphones are dying
all right guys so we're doing it we're
still going hard um
we're making ghibli renders and uh
you know it's certainly certainly a lot
of work involved in doing this
it's just a ton of ton of block out
stuff a ton of modeling
a ton of texturing but it's nice to have
a friend
um doing this with
um so peter if you can hear me in the
stream
i just lost you on the phone you have to
call me back so i can hear you again
let's see if i can't get like a banister
going
all right
maybe what we'll do is we'll make a cube
yo hey can you hear me yeah
okay sweet all right yeah my airpods
died
yeah i realized when i was charging my
headphones they weren't even charging i
was like oh no
oh god dude these bone phones blow my
mind
they're so cool do you have some right
now yeah i'm wearing them
oh did you just get some yeah my mom got
them for me for my birthday that's
really sweet oh dude
yeah they're great i got a switch i got
the bone phones next step one wheel
heck yeah dude do you really think
you're gonna get one
a onewheel yeah i don't know man
maybe maybe i just want electric
rollerblades that's all i want oh dude
heck yeah
that'd be super sick
all right so i'm just going to clone
this thing across
the way here boom linear cloner
we'll go this way i'm just looking at
the reference here it just kind of goes
all the way across
then always set yourself to multi
instance that way
you get the most out of your computer
input
all right that totally works
and i don't think i need it on the other
side i think i'm just going to do
let's see
duplicate this stuff here ctrl drag
up and smush it down
we can always bevel this stuff after the
fact but you definitely want a bevel
though because
you'll catch the light in a really nice
way and you don't want to miss out on
that
whoa this grass world stuff is really
cool
all right what are you working on peter
dude i'm just freaking
getting this grass going son heck yeah i
like your foreground stuff
yeah nice so you're you're kind of
you're getting close
yeah we're getting there i don't i don't
know if i would say close but we're
definitely
coming along populating it with
grass and stuff it's just
this is going to be quite a beastly
little render here
yeah seriously
all right let's see here density let's
turn that up to
20 see how that looks
oh baby seriously man tell me about it
[Laughter]
wow i think that's looking good it's
just noise
so hard to tell
nice though man i think you seem like
your variation of grass right
yeah yeah totally it's it's pretty
uniform right now
it's my volumetric cube i'm gonna turn
that off see if that helps at all
oh god that's so much better
okay yeah this is just like mush right
here
dude i want to like sit on that it feels
like really nice
variant
[Music]
what the heck really a good idea to
learn like a
software before you like go live using
it
dude i have been there man oh yeah
100
play as
weird
workbench that's amazing
winslow's asking what ghibli art is it's
basically uh
there's a there's a company in japan
called studio studio ghibli
and they make movies like spirited away
or house moving castle
or totoro just google it and you'll be
like oh i've seen these before
they're amazing movies man they're some
of the best
it's like each frame in that movie is
just like a new
incredible painting yeah absolutely
um marcelo as asking what lod
is you want to explain yeah yeah that
stands for level of detail it's
most commonly used in video games like
you'll notice sometimes uh
if you're like walking through a forest
you see a tree in the background and as
you get like a little bit closer to it
it kind of pops into a higher quality
version and then once you get really
close to it it pops into the highest
quality version
and that's just so that your video game
or your cg scene isn't having to render
the
highest quality like most taxing
versions of the assets
at the same time always it can kind of
blend things in and out of quality
to save your computer from having to
render all that and you can do that with
cgi too you know you have a version of
your asset that's just like
one square with the picture on it and
then that's for like super far
away and then once it gets a little bit
closer it switches to a very low polygon
and then it just keeps increasing in
polygons until you're right next to it
it's just a nice way to save your
performance yeah
very crucial when like you know you're
you have those larger scenes you know if
you're doing something small it doesn't
it's not that big of a deal but when you
got
larger scenes going it's really nice to
use that and like we we kind of talked
about an hour ago about like
using 2k textures until you need to
upgrade to a 4k texture or an 8k texture
that's like another way of kind of doing
it manually you're using the lower level
of detail
until you need to manually switch to the
higher level of detail
um totally yeah
all right peter keep going i'm so hungry
i'm gonna grab a cookie i'll be back
all right man
what is p compute number of particles
using plants per square meter instead of
usual
density
oh and i am just trying to figure out
grasswall
this is a really cool software but
i also have no idea
how to do that so we're kind of figuring
that out species should i change the
species
orchard grass variant
oh that's cool can you like add
hmm does anybody know
how to for grass walled to add multiple
oh you know what it's the outliner you
probably add another one
boom there we go create new settings
oh okay species let's do
freaking i don't have flowers
dang weeds
god my computer is chugging
curly dock dandelion ooh they do have
flowers nice
okay heck yeah
do some dandelions do some freaking
dandelions
okay i'm gonna turn down this grass a
little bit because it's
super dense
all right turn down that size a little
bit
yo yo yo yo yo how's your cookie
i mean it's about to be great nice
i'm going to turn the grass off so we
can just see the dandelions
density paint oh nice we can paint
exactly
where we want the dandelions perfect
okay so
do like some right here
and just let's make this easier to see
huh let's
do a horizontal split of the viewport
and we can look at this through here and
then look at the
reference on top okay so we want some
dandelions around there
a little over here
some over here
do some of that
turn down the weight add a little bit
more variety
we want like we don't want it to be like
all dandelions and then no dandelions we
want kind of a gradient of dandelions
going around
cool so then i'm going to turn the
weight up a bit more
go in here to where they're very dense
kind of the focus of the scene
and that right there
[Music]
kind of really focus this area on the
flowers
maybe add some more density right here
sweet okay let's see how that looks go
back into object mode
and grass walled where you at okay
we calculate density there we go all
right
let's turn up that density turn up the
size a little bit
what's up chris thanks for the super
chat man
drink for peter thanks for joining yeah
yeah evolvers uh always watching the
streams man
thank you revolver you're very kind it's
so good to have
someone else on this stream dude oh my
god
being able to switch over every once in
a while yeah seriously
man
all right
um i would love to like push these into
the ground a little bit
length oh length
length oh that's
really cool what happened oh
i just you can uh in griswold which is
this like
foliage plug-in you can create uh like a
vertex
paint thing for the length so you can
paint
areas where you want the plants to be
longer and shorter which is nice thank
you
let's see if that works so
let's do that and that's and then
that see if that does anything
oh it works that's super sweet but it
changes the scale not the length which
is no bueno for us
new
grass wall dandelion heck yeah okay
so if i go in here trash the length
and then can i just move this down
yes it works
okay so let's just select all of these
little dandelions
move that down into the ground heck
yeah son all right
now we're talking
oh that's so sweet kaylee brought me
some
fruits thanks dude that's great
[Music]
so let's see how we're looking what um
which which ghibli movies have you seen
i have seen how's moving castle
that's a good way
and uh my neighbor totoro and i'm
halfway through princess mononoke
oh nice yeah that's a really far i've
um my neighbor totoro was like not my
favorite i
enjoyed it but it it wasn't like
gripping to me yeah
but how's moving castle and spirited
away were just
so good yeah absolutely incredible
spirited away was the first one i saw
yeah it's i'm so happy they're all on uh
hbo max now yep you can just
roll through them oh dude porca rosso is
great yeah porca rosso is one of my
favorites
i wanna watch that it's good and then
you gotta watch uh
like i think one of the most fun ghibli
movies
is uh lupin the third
it's about like where's that gentleman's
spy and it's so cool
that's awesome or he's a thief
damn i gotta watch that yeah it's great
all right so i'm just throwing in my
flowers now add a little more density
turn up the size
cool okay see how that works
this grass wall plug-in is wonderful
that's awesome
heck yeah all right oh those flowers
look great
dude
awesome that's super nice yeah
okay you know what i'm going to do is
i'm going to
show only my ground flame and i'm going
to take
these dandelion lines and i'm going to
change the material
so each instance of it has
a random color so we can
select the color palette from the
screenshot here oh that's awesome
so let's split the view go into the
shader editor
and i'm going to select the dandelion
flower material
oh wow this is a really intense material
oh my goodness
okay so color oh jesus christ
oh good god that's advanced dude
there's so much [ __ ]
okay i think i know what i have to do
though i'm just going to add hue
changers right in front of
each of where the colors are coming out
of
okay this is oh that's the normal map
don't want to screw with that
this is color color old oh what up cliff
cliff here yeah cliff's here hell yeah
what's up cliff
we're gonna hang out tonight oh nice
what are you guys gonna do
i'll probably get into some drummond
maybe some 3d modeling
oh nice is cliff doing 3d stuff yeah
he's learning blender
oh that's awesome dude cliff hit me up
yeah we were i was showing him one of
your tutorials on like how to do hdr
eyes and stuff
oh awesome yeah cliff son what up son
he says show me the ways
i'm almost done cutting out all of the
holes for like
my uh my windows and stuff
nice it's just taking a minute
yeah okay let's see if this is working
like at all
we want a random value
um they say uh grasswald has settings to
change the colors
well that's awesome dude it's so great
having like help as you work
yeah seriously i've learned so much
doing it this way like legit yeah
you can change those make it look dry
what
this is awesome you can change that yo
cg studio we get it we get it you can
change the age of the grass
and make it look dried in the age
settings too
page settings maybe in material oh
what oh my god it's just a freaking
slider dude her age
yeah that's amazing percentage
using this uh grass
let's see material
show albedo only that's helpful
i don't know if this has
function to randomize the color that i
can see
not quite sure
you guys know where this random color
thing is
let peter know um
says use a color ramp and a random
inputter into the vector
yeah that's the original plan i'm gonna
go back to that
um they say it it has advanced settings
too
that's advanced settings
i think this thing has everything
okay advanced
anybody know where the advanced settings
are
the secret advanced settings yeah what
the heck
uh it says a check box the check box
check box overall settings
scene settings edit preferences add-on
oh it's in there
oh wow under materials advanced settings
wait
material how am i not seeing this
oh it's probably the materials tab maybe
let's prove the polygon material
confirmed
[Music]
oh maybe it's in this
dude i don't freaking know
all right i'm just gonna do the nodes
all right i'm gonna switch back over
here nice
all right so i am using booleans
to cut out little areas
for the uh the light to shine through
i'm just trying to make sure i have like
an edge here
so it has like something to shine just
as a little edge
you know just to catch the light in a
nice way
boom and then i'll just make this
editable
and combine all this stuff
and just delete these faces here
and that'll open it up to the inside
and i'll just put some lights in there
cool let me drop those down
yeah sweet and just light up the room
like that
it looks like the bottom is open so i
got to close that up
so if you do say let's select this
and hit md the way i think it is like a
medical doctor these patching holes
so that's how you patch a hole md that's
the shortcut
boom close it up
i'll go back to camera view
and it's coming together certainly
coming together you can lock
your uh your render view here
in octane make sure you save
big angry welcome you got off work
just in time yeah doing the dual stream
peter you still got dudes like looking
up grass walled for you oh no way
yeah because it's so nice on the grass
webpage they say you can change color
saturation in more settings
but maybe it's only in the oh
i do not
i have the
version so maybe that's
it
we'll figure it out
see my computer is like working so hard
to do all this stuff at once
dude same oh my god and you're streaming
that's intense
all right let's see we can yeah we can
lock the viewport here and you should
be presented with some numbers there we
go
and then you can like lower this down
and see your whole image
it looks like we need to see a little
bit more
of the left or the right side
i'm going to move our camera over
just zoom out maybe a little bit
yeah that works
these lights are too bright too and cut
these guys down
and the roof tile like let's just try
and make those roof tiles like
really reflective
what if we take down the roughness we
just take it off completely we look at
the specular make sure that's
yup up 1.3 okay
or maybe we just control the roughness
on its own let me
boost that up
and maybe we load in an actual hdri
image here so let's let's give that a
shot instead of a color let's like
actually do
a sky or something so
hmm i duplicated the octane sky in
whichever one's on top
is the hdri that will be present so i'll
switch over to an image
and we'll load
some hdri haven textures
where are you there you are skies
cool and we'll just try these out
that's obviously way too bright
and let's try and rotate it around
and and dim it down like a by a bunch
but honestly i kind of like what we had
before i didn't i thought just
a color wasn't that bad actually
because essentially it is just a really
super overcast sky like that is the look
and feel
you can come in here and like add some
stuff uh later
in photoshop or whatever but like this
is really is like the look and feel of
what we're trying to go for
um you again yeah this will stay
uploaded when we're done streaming for
sure
yeah everyone i do this every saturday
they all uh
all on my on my youtube page
what's up fruit juice fruit juice
he's a regular heck yeah
ben why am i using reference
man you always got to use reference
that's how you
get to what you're getting to probably
in the fastest most accurate way
it'll really guide the process
especially if you're trying to go for
stuff like
um if you're trying to go for stuff
that's based off of something
or is trying to feel like real life you
always want to reference it man that's
like
you save yourself so much time and it
really helps define what you're creating
so
i recommend you use reference for
everything um
pureref is a great program it's allowing
me to keep my image always on top
so it's super cool it's so easy to go
ask you when you're working on something
you know you you just get so up in your
own head of how it should look and
kind of lose sight of what should
actually look like yeah
absolutely you kind of like get stuck
and you go off on a tangent and like
realize wait i went all the way out this
way and it didn't work but sometimes
like that's cool like sometimes you do
want to like
try ideas um that's true but yeah use
reference when you can
how are you feeling about your piece
right now peter dude good i got these
flowers going check it out
let's see i think you're i think your
video's frozen again
no
no it should work it's looking good in
discord really
yeah i think
well anyway people can still hear you
and they can still see you
let me uh i'll stop streaming and go
again
there it is
they they want to know where you got the
name ganga
here wait till your wait till your video
comes back and then you got to explain
it
no
oh there's no audio either
yeah you died
all right peter will be back guys in a
second
all right there's so much more to be
done in this image man it's like there's
a lot of haziness going on here
um that we need to take care of like i
think you can probably do this
in you know in after effects probably or
not after effects with photoshop you can
get some of this haze down
but really we got to spend a ton of time
getting these like
getting these textures looking good man
all right am i working yeah we see you
sweet
all right riley wait can i hear me yeah
i'm here yeah i see you you got levels
okay great yeah okay so this is ganga
you're explaining this to our stream
audience awesome
um where am i uh you are no
i'm not here here what's the video
what is this like milk toast background
all right hi everybody uh my name is
riley olsen i am peter's um
sassy untalented gay roommate uh
housemate uh
okay i'm here talented shut up i'm also
really good at fishing
for compliments uh but no so um everyone
knows star wars
and our favorite the phantom menace um
and there are
the gungans uh but in in a specific
interview
george lucas calls them goongaz
which is funny um but i was joking with
uh peter and his friend
matt once and we were quoting jar jar
binks
you know the classic um how wood
like we're like lisa gonna go home
so um that happens um
and the man says i'm sorry you want to
do what it's like
you know the jar jar quote where he says
misawa sniffer ganga
he wants to sniff your ganga um so
things just keep going from there it was
at my place we were in my room watching
things on my projector
and i was like is that actually a scene
from the movie oh yeah so manna came up
with this
without peter and then we told peter
that it's an actual line from the movie
obviously
and they were like search for it on
youtube yeah he says it he says it to
liam neeson he says he wants to sniff
liam eason's gunga but humans don't have
gungas 10 minutes trying to find this
one
you guys just let me try
yeah no we um so i think eventually it's
failed that
that that is not a line did you pull up
a script too
no i just tried to found out i was like
gunga snippy fungus
sniffing scene so it became a lawyer
that there is i want to say a gland or a
body part
called the gunga or a material it's kind
of like
yeah you really don't know what it is or
where it is that um
people want to sniff so gunga sniffing
became a thing
um and then it also became a catch-all
term for like
disgusting things that are gross like
definitely if there's like some gross
stuff
like in a pot or something just like
look at that gunga in there
and then there's also the cinematic the
gunga cinematic universe
which is an ip we're starting to try i'm
trying to get started
you need to make that scene in blender
um
we should make that in blender welcome
to gun golf
oh my god we can mocap it and everything
get riley in the mocap suit
riley is very familiar with that mo
capsule i am he played the cg character
this is scooty but i am scooty from uh
the titular role
in uh wait is the same dude who had his
head blown up
in your tutorial don't you have you yes
you put ganga into different things in
scooty
it's in the background of like every
shot yeah well because there's gunka
corp
that was the first one you said you had
to add was a billboard and then there's
gunga air on the air
[Laughter]
but uh yeah riley made the mocap suit
real stinky
it was the only person wearing it and b
we were doing a lot of physical activity
it's fine ah good times you better get
back to blind yeah
um so um thank you everyone for
listening to the tale of
the gun gun thanks for the story good
stuff dude
all right where are we at man what
what's like
there's no way i'm finishing this
there's no way to understand this
i believe in you you got this dude if i
had all day but i don't have all day
there's so much to do here look i'm
gonna be so bummed if you don't finish
your thing
this is where i'm at like this looks
like
this is so bad this is like the
beginning of
the end yeah can you
the stream is so delayed i can't see
it's like it's it's it just needs so
much more
work at this point like it's craziness
where are you at
um oh hold on i have to watch your
stream hold on one second one second
all right there we are we're getting
there
we're definitely getting there it's not
perfect it's definitely a lot of work no
but it's coming along it's coming along
it looks really good though dude
thanks man yeah i appreciate that like
what dude what's left to do what's up in
your eyes on this
yeah i mean i gotta take these flowers
got to populate them everywhere else
i gotta add the little dude in there
which won't be too hard but then
it's it's pretty much from here it's
just detail and lighting
little visual tricks to get it to look
good and it's that thing where like i've
already done
80 of the work but that last 20 it's
gonna take like
80 of my time you know yep that's
that's it dude yeah that's freaking it
wait did somebody just send a thousand
dollars
no it's huff what is huff i don't know
okay
yeah it'd be insane no that'd be crazy
i i used to think i was like oh my god a
thousand dollars
i think it's um i think it's like two
bucks or something because like
basically it's like
if you send five bucks it'll be up for
five minutes if you send ten it'll be
for ten minutes you know that kind of
stuff oh
yeah that's cool but man i really
appreciate all these super chats from
you guys you guys are
really going hard um thank you so much
samu i see you
um yeah it's hungarian florence
that's what huff is i guess oh that's
okay and yeah
dude nice that's awesome that's super
nice
yeah we'll have to go and get a really
nice thick dinner together
dude i'm so done
so let's say we take the next like
the next 30 minutes to do what we can
here
and then if you still have time um
we can hop in and um judge
the top five winners for the color
contest like all those images i was
showing you yesterday
yeah yeah let's do it sure sweet so yeah
let's let's do that let's say like it
um in 30 minutes we'll hop into that but
let's just keep pushing on
on our renders here and see how far we
can get them sweet love it
cool all right i'm throwing these
headphones let me see if these
headphones work now
cool
yo can you hear me
oh my god it's not working
peter say something
god dang it why not work on my phone
dude
i'm gonna call you back i'm gonna call
you back right
oh no
nothing let me try some other headphones
all right i'm going to add another
grasswald system here
this is just too fun
oh blender says no lender says spare me
what's up son yeah it works now
cool let me switch to my aftershocks
all right yo we got mr dinklewinkle up
in here he's one of the mods
on the discord server and
up here in the chat so shout outs
we're going to spend the next 30 minutes
here um
and make our vendors look really nice
and then we're going to go into
the the weekly challenge winners and
announce the next challenge
so that's that's where we're at right
now peter can you hear me all good
i'm working on it okay
there we go hey
yo clip yo
all right cool cool cool
so much to be done ready i'm gonna add
some seriously
got some red clovers here
all right i'm gonna switch back to my
end here
i am yeah we still 700 people still up
in here dude like
it is awesome yeah try to keep the
entertainment value up as much as we can
honestly all right so for my render here
i got a bunch of like windows and i'm
trying to fill in now that i got all
these empty little spots here
so i'm gonna go in and fill up and i'll
fill all these like window frames in
um try and populate this with as much of
that as possible
and then i'm probably gonna go in and
start working on like
some of these wooden beams i'll start
bringing in some assets from from qixel
and stuff
so nice heck yeah yeah
yeah just go quick and dirty dude yeah
all right
um get these windows in the right spot
here
peter what's your favorite part with uh
with creating and rendering stuff
favorite part that's a great question
damn
i've been getting really into lighting
recently nice it's so fun it's crazy how
much
you can change a scene based on the
light
you know you can give it a completely
different feel without like
doing anything besides changing the
position of the lights
yeah yeah i definitely agree with you on
that man lighting is
everything um and you can spend so long
on lighting too it's crazy yeah honestly
yeah lighting and i love making things
look real like texturing things really
nice feels so good
mm-hmm yeah what's your favorite part
i'd say the surface imperfections and
texturing
um and then like being able to change
the lighting at the end of your piece
and get different looks from it totally
totally yeah yeah it's 3dr so 3d art is
nice in that way that you can always
just make a scene
and then you have like infinite
iterations you can make
yeah yeah exactly which is
pretty nuts actually with crypto art
because you can just do different
versions of your scene like
different weather patterns and stuff oh
man yeah totally
are you do you think you're gonna get
into that
i don't know maybe it's uh
maybe i'm not quite sure it's it's
definitely not
like calling my name super hard but
it would be nice to make some moolah you
know yeah
yeah definitely i know i really want to
get into it i'm like
itching to get in i got i finally got
accepted on one of the sites
oh heck yeah dude that's awesome yeah um
so i'm just waiting for my
acceptance on on the other ones before i
get stuff going so
um yeah yeah totally
nice that's gonna be super fun yeah
agreed
um so samuel says i was playing with my
friend
um so couldn't catch much of the last
hour
dang you guys are fast and awesome at 3d
can you bring someone in with 3ds
max next time oh no offense grab nico
yeah nico or sam or uh even ren was in
3ds max for a minute
yep
i'm gonna start bringing in some trees
oh i bought a nice
tree pack from blender market oh for
real
mm-hmm
which one it's like uh
just like trees
nice freaking discord crapped out
oh again well i got it down to a science
now turning it back on
cool yeah we see you
sweet dude cliff's back
heck yeah
so peter do you play any uh
traditional instruments
sort of i i mostly just play the
computer you know
as far as music definitely but uh
but i play a little drums a little
keyboard and a little guitar
i'm not good at any of them but i can
like mess around on all of them
like just enough to like get something
in the computer
yeah yeah or like jam out heck yeah
yeah what about you you play drums right
yeah i play drums cliff plays drums
cliff also plays uh guitar and bass but
yeah i'm drums
and a little bit of bass a little bit of
piano so we're gonna we're gonna
hang out tonight and just like play some
music and
do some three oh it's awesome dude yeah
that's gonna be fun as heck
oh yeah
you ever think you'll get into like
making music yeah i think i think later
in life
i'd like to actually make some ambient
music maybe some electronic music
oh that would be sweet you should
definitely do that yeah man it'd be
super fun
so man yeah this is just tedious placing
windows like
over and over and over you got this on
yeah yes so when you guys are doing your
3d
art you just got to stick with it you
know um
an hour a day just knocking out
different pieces of art you know keep
keep at it for sure
it's also nice to get a nice uh blend of
spending a lot of time on stuff
and spending a little time on stuff yeah
you know you have like a
a bunch of little tiny projects to keep
you going and then every once in a while
you devote a little more time to
something something nicer you flex all
those muscles you know
yeah dude that's why i love like having
so many different hobbies
honestly um totally it just allows me to
you know to stay interested in all the
different stuff i'm doing um
yeah our different little projects as
long as you finish your stuff you just
gotta finish your stuff really
yeah that's the hardest part
all right got my first tree in here i'm
gonna switch over to you
all right oh it's on discord
god damn it
uh let's see here we go there we go
share screen there you are i see you
cool all right
let's get you pulled up here
bam yeah you're in sweet
okay
we got our reference image on the left
here we got our scene
on the right here i'm going to switch
over to material preview so you can see
easier what's going on
gotta let the shaders compile a little
bit
okay so right now
i'm just gonna place these trees in here
although this is gonna be pretty even
though it's low poly
still kind of high poly so i'm going to
decimate that a bit
maybe go down to 0.3
let that choke a little bit might
completely destroy it
hopefully not oh yeah that's fine cool
oh wait what am i even applying that to
[ __ ]
i feel like i lose my mind when i stream
i'm like i don't know what i'm doing
dude me too
damn's already two yeah seriously
all right not edge split oh god
decimate
somebody in chat saying blender is not
bad for 2d animation i've heard that
i've never done it but i've heard great
things about it i would like to try it
sometime
i think yeah grease pencil you use for
that
the greasy pencil and greasy pencil
yeah that's the name of the tool grease
pencil
like frielda that's cool
let's place some cute little tree
action in here i'm gonna make this trunk
a little bit thicker
a little bit longer
so the view on the right is that your
full render view right now
uh no this is just material preview it's
kind of like the video game style render
got you cool yeah it's nice for when you
want to
roughly see what things are going to
look like but don't render the whole
thing yeah
all right just making this tree trunk a
little bit thicker
thick boy over here
that's a little better
all right place more of those alt d
that all over the place
someone's asking if i've been able to
convert anybody else in the office to
blender
i have not but probably once a day
someone is like oh man i should
blender once a day
maybe eventually dude here
i can your freaking discord's oh it's
back okay it's back
god damn it the constant battle dude
but there's a lot of respect going
around on the chat so that's cool
awesome constant respect
um samu thank you again for the super
chat he says any free or not too
hard on the wallet material sites you
would recommend
um dude um
[Music]
texture haven it's the hdr haven
equivalent for textures yep i was gonna
say the same thing
heck yeah and it's all like pbr stuff
right
yeah i think so um that's awesome they
also have
hdri haven and model haven now
mm-hmm but dude they took down their
guns from model what why i don't know
god dang it i know they were so nice too
i don't know
all right 15 more minutes
alright son
we're getting there yep
it's all about persistence man you just
gotta stick with it
seriously
like it'd be legit to make these
animated backgrounds
oh man like ford yeah i mean
that'll be amazing
did i just realize my angles are all off
like
what do you mean everything's off by
like two degrees so it's not lined up
perfectly
oh god but that's probably fine i think
it's fine yeah because it kind of adds
to the
like handmade feel of this whole thing
totally
heck yeah
okay i'm gonna add
a grass material here
just uh for the ground so it doesn't
look so
maybe a forest ground nice
this one looks pretty good
dude qixel is so nice
it's the freaking best i don't know what
i would do without it
all right and just the fact that you can
export it straight into blender in c40
or whatever
puts it miles ahead of any other
i know polygon you can do a similar
thing it's
it requires like one more step
but it's still pretty good yeah i just
love the ability to like these
because you don't want to be like
clicking through you know
different like menu trees and everything
for the rest of your life you want to be
able to just
work and create you know yeah that's
what
bridge does such a good job of
alleviating um george
yo thank you so much man thanks for the
super chat and thanks for joining we'll
see you
next week man same place thank you
george
george yeah
man have you messed with like the ian
hubert method where you just like
projection map everything
a little bit yeah it works surprisingly
well
i bet man like i feel like i need to be
doing that right now
yeah i mean it's just such a great way
to get like instant detail because you
you get those little microbiomes you
know that exists in the corners of
things
yeah man that's that that's that's that
detail that's super necessary
and yeah it just like
yeah the detail you get is like
unparalleled because
it's like actually from a photograph and
what you lack in your modeling you make
up for and just details in a photo that
look like they're modeled and they're
not
it's amazing yeah
oh i'm so close
you got this man
wait dude your squirrel mouse sounds
like a freaking dude like pushing a rock
across
like the concrete at least from my like
from my uh
how i hear you on your phone right now
that's funny yeah
yeah i i unlocked it so it uh doesn't do
that anymore
it's chill it's just funny
all right um i'm going to switch this
out
to a grass and rubble well actually
grass wild boom
one
boom
i'm gonna switch back to me
i'm so close to getting this thing
blocked out
and like got all my window frames in
except for like this last one and one
other
that's looking really good son thanks
man
perfect so close
people are asking what 3d scanning app i
use on the phone i use a
polycam on the iphone to do like this
quick little instant 3d scans but
for the more high quality ones i use a
dslr with reality capture
that's definitely the best one i found
dude reality capture is so cool i got it
because i mean well sam used it a lot
but then you when we did those scans for
uh
the freaking what is it the video we did
with oh yeah the time capsule
the time capsule yeah that's what sold
me on it dude it's so good
it's also just so fast yeah
oh man
all right last one is just this little
guy right here
right in there
see if i can like copy this stuff
cheat cheat when you can
all right i think it's time for some
more mega scans
mega scans on mega scans on mega scans
yeah
mitch is asking how are we doing a live
stream together dude i don't even know
man like we kind of figured it out like
15 minutes before we went live and it
was pretty stressful
but we figured it out dude um
it's like through discord and obs and
it's just craziness like it'll be better
the next time
yeah clint pulled it together it was
very impressive
somehow peter can attest to how stressed
out i was before we started this whole
thing he was very stressed
dude i can't wait to get some lunch
after this oh i'm starving yeah
boom all right that feels good and we'll
just copy
our lights
sweet
all right let's see if i can just line
this up
nice
boom that looks pretty freaking good i
just need to
lock it up back there it's a little
looking great man thank you
yeah it's just a little dark back there
so yeah you can go option
uncheck the check camera option which
always confusing
but yeah i'll just move this stuff up
and try and like get the wall
to come forward just a little bit
boom there we go
grab this guy push it forward
all right that's i mean that's the
blockout basically right there
oh and then there's so much more detail
to do after that oh my goodness
oh boy oh oh boy is right um
where are you at peter what's going on
over here i'm uh nearing the final
stages here
heck yeah yeah just uh throwing in some
more plants
making it look all nice you want to take
like five more minutes
[Music]
yeah yeah sounds good okay um i'm gonna
step
step away for a small break here and
then i'll be back in like yeah
i'll be back in like two minutes okay
sounds good son all right
all right y'all i'm just grabbing these
mega scan plants
throw them in trying to make it look a
little bit random you know
nothing rotated too perfectly or
scattered too uniformly
randomness always helps making things
feel alive
i'm taking a little bit of creative
liberty with my plants here because
you know i don't know i'd like to fill
out the scene a little bit more
mega scans is nice because they give you
a ton of
different assets like for each flower
you'll get like
seven different versions of the flower
but i usually
end up just like duplicating three of
them
because you really don't need that many
variations of the same thing you can
just
scale it and rotate it and move it
around and it looks like a different
plant
oh
yo yo yo yo my dude
we're about to wrap up y'all um it's
been a long one we've been streaming for
oh how long three and a half hours
oh blender crashed i hope i saved oh
[ __ ]
uh tell me i saved oh no dude
okay i saved recently oh i saved in like
the last 10 seconds that's amazing
oh man oh we got a 30 donation that's so
nice
30 euros son that's 30
euros melanie thank you melanie it's
been a long time it's good to see you
again he's very kind she says uh hey
clint this is looking great
um i hope you and the cats are doing
well yes um teddy
and uh gilbert are doing very well
they're
chilling right now and
she says what's up peter good to have
you back at corridor
greetings from snowy helsinki
hey hey thank you it is lovely to be
back
yeah dude you finally got a place down
in l.a
i know it's so nice having a house
um i'm very grateful to be employed and
be able to
seriously have a house and stuff
seriously man yeah
absolutely um
i think it's time i think it's time
for cutting me off yeah we're gonna
we're gonna do the uh announce the
weekly challenge winners
and we'll take a look at those um i
gotta get lunch
my knees are hurting i've been standing
up this whole time dude
oh you're using your standing desk dang
yeah
oh my goodness um all right can you give
me a final like view
of where you're at right now yeah let me
uh i just need to throw a quick
like ocean texture on this
plane cool i'm gonna switch over to me
here this is
this is where i'm at i'm at like
basically got my block out
um i cut out all of the windows here
i placed all my window frames and i lit
the scene
and kind of made it feel
close to the image here definitely see a
little bit more purple you can probably
change that in the white balance in
octane you can set it to
green and it goes the opposite way nice
dude that's a great start that's looking
awesome it's gonna be a
[ __ ] sick render yeah man i'm excited
i'm like
if i can get the rain and some sound
design right i could just do like
an hour long video or something like an
hour loop
yeah you could probably even use like
ember gen or something to make some
volumetrics for the
for the rain hitting the roof or
something oh dude yes but
that might be a lot of work might be
better to just comp that i'd be sick
though
yeah um so yeah like i definitely bit
off more than i could chew as i always
do
and but it's looking cool like i
definitely look forward to coming back
to this and
and working on this throughout the week
um or maybe on the next stream we'll see
but um yeah where you at peter what you
got
um yeah hold on let me freakin add this
ocean
super quick just a quick ocean no big
deal
so what are you doing are you doing uh
deform
yeah so blender has a little ocean
modifier which is awesome it just
gives you waves and stuff
good god
okay this ocean needs to chill the heck
out
okay ocean scale down
okay boom
then let's make that just metallic
turn the roughness all the way down
and then nice it looks like a normal map
yeah pretty much
okay waves
skill
ah that's awesome i wish c40 had
something like that
they have hot4d which is houdini
ocean something or yeah it's basically
houdini's like ocean thing but
for cinema 4d and it's a little janky
and it's not really supported
in to like the current versions of c40
which sucks
dang that's a bummer
almost at a thousand likes y'all hit
those like buttons
right now because we gotta get to yeah
samu with the freaking super chat again
thank you um he's digging it he loves
the feel of your render peter
um oh from the start yeah and the tips
and the start with broad lines
attitude um is super awesome so
that's great yeah man all right let's
throw that volumetric cube back in there
and i'm gonna go ahead and hit render
see what happens
on my freaking gpu good luck to
both our computers
yeah hit render and then we'll um we'll
do we'll show the winners
of this thing and then we can come back
and take a look sweet
we had some uber quick depth of field
yeah do you think you guys are amazing
thank you so much for all
the super chats um me and peter will
definitely get a nice dinner
with uh with all of this stuff thank you
thank you so much
um yeah thank you everybody for tuning
in and donating stuff it's
so nice yeah people are so nice dude
seriously
and there you go dude there you go
um there's peter peter's coming back
yeah there he is he's loading in um
yeah we see you so from here basically
we're gonna go into the art review every
single week
i hold a challenge where i ask you guys
to render something create something
from a prompt
um if you guys are part of the discord
already the link's in the description
it's super fun we have 7 000 members
since
last year since we started this so it's
like wow
it's so freaking cool yeah it's awesome
um
it's been really inspiring to see
everyone's work and like you guys are
putting in
more and more like quality work
every single week and it's becoming
really difficult to choose these winners
so
um i'm very excited to do this uh
peter do you have your render rendering
yeah check it out the freaking flowers
exploded
oh hold on
oh they're just like bam flowers oh my
goodness that's ridiculous
you're frozen again too god damn it
oh man we got the 1000 likes that's
great thank you guys that's great and
hey if you guys aren't subscribed
already and you guys are enjoying this
subscribe um why not you know it's a lot
of fun
peter's youtube is also in the
description so subscribe to peter too
he's got a lot of good blender tutorials
so don't miss those as well
thanks man yeah i got some more stuff
coming it's gonna be a good time
yeah all right so
those flowers are looking crazy um yeah
a little crazy
definitely you know would need like
another hour of work
before it's instagram worthy for sure
but uh
this is where we are and i'm happy with
i'm happy with it cool
yeah um are you ready to check out some
sick renders from
from some people yeah son let's do it
all right so you got to fix your
freaking
video again because it's frozen but oh
okay um on second thought though i think
it's chill because
i didn't put your face on
the art review
quite yet but i will let me throw you in
here real quick
um let me see let's find out let me
let me add you
boom scene bear with me all while i add
peter to the art review thing so we can
do this together
uh there hey there's peter
okay could you possibly share your
screen with me because the the youtube
feed is like
way behind oh is it yeah
okay um i think so
maybe can i
i'm trying to just like try to stack you
on this is hilarious
oh my goodness i'll just put you up over
here
here we go bear with me all we're doing
edits on the fly here okay so
dang i'd have to share like how's this
even gonna work
how far behind is the stream from your
perspective
give me a star with my video
oh you're i'm like lining you up
yeah like like give me a star oh a star
like with my hands right now oh yeah
sure yeah i guess you could just like
give me a thumbs up or something
there's a heart in the screen there's
some good content right here
did you see the heart yet nope
shoot okay i don't know okay there's the
heart
there's the heart all right i'll just
talk about how sick these renders are
until until you see them all right so
here we go
um the first person
the first person to win the weekly
challenge is
willy with this incredible render it's
the one that i showed you the ian hubert
style one
yesterday with like the cart the
shopping cart in the middle and the with
the
oh dude that one was amazing yeah it's
like not okay
you said that guy is 13 years old yeah
he's like 13. is is ridiculous that's
not okay like what are you doing dude um
you're dealing with some darkness or
something yeah it's insane
like the color it's all modeled from
scratch yeah it is all modeled from
scratch it's crazy
nuts so it looks incredible the prompt
was color
um so when i'm looking at these winners
i'm really trying to figure out like
how did you mess with uh you know with
color theory
do you have contrasting colors like i
see the red and the green which are at
the
opposite ends of the color spectrum the
color wheel so that's why they
are complementing each other um you have
tertiary colors as well which are like
you form a triangle
on the color wheel and you get that um
so the blue and the green look really
nice together um along with the red
there too and
i i super dig this i think it's awesome
so
yeah um wren was saying it looks like a
scene out of soul or something like that
oh dude it totally does it the detail's
crazy
yeah it's amazing so congrats william
you get
the challenge winner role this week on
the discord so keep it up keep
the awesome renders coming man you do
amazing
amazing stuff all right number two
um who is number two
it's gonna be jason um with the image of
the girl in the grass with the glasses
uh we got the red hair
that one's great yeah really really nice
um
color here again you got the red and the
green the opposite colors here your
render quality is through the roof
um it's freaking awesome
the skin shader is fantastic and the
lips that's amazing
i know i'm just like this is such a a
weakness for me um
doing people and yeah this is
yeah it is hard dude this is one of the
best that i've seen like
when it comes to like just doing it in a
week obviously there's those guys on
instagram doing like
renders of old people that just look
ridiculous you know
but this looks really nice yeah
um so jason congratulations you got the
challenge winner roll this week on the
discord server keep it up
keep making awesome render so you can
hang on to it because next week it might
be taken from you
we'll see we will have to see
all right next up
see next up we got bam
mdk with this awesome animation of this
paint tube
spitting out all different kinds of
paint onto this little work area
dude i love that one i know yeah it's so
good should have been in the
corridor simulation challenge i know
it's super satisfying like if it had
like you know all the sound design and
everything on it it would just be
incredible but like the glowing
uh paint is perfect
and it loops perfectly love how the
the paint coming out of the tube it kind
of crinkles the tube a little bit
that's crazy it does crinkle the two and
fold up that's awesome
and that whipped cream what the heck
yeah
so sick yeah good color
um composition here you got the blue and
the green the army men
on the opposite um colored mats i wonder
if that's grace go gorilla it looks
like their textures it's hard to tell
but
i dig your colors you did it in a really
cool way um
and your render quality is through the
roof so mdk congrats on this one
you get the challenge winner roll and uh
yeah keep it up keep up the good work
heck yeah all right two more
two more so we got bam
one dead duck is the second to last
winner
this week um super sick color i love the
aqua
blue and green mixed with the gold and
the orange like dude i just
love this color style so much
oh that's lovely yeah it looks really
really nice
really cute little fishies yeah
seriously
there's just so many um submissions this
week guys so i really appreciate it
your guys's stuff is amazing and it's
been harder and harder
to judge these pieces of art and i know
there's a lot of incredible ones that i
hadn't touched on
obviously we still have one more winner
but i really try and look for color
because that was that was it you know
um you could have had a really really
awesome render
but you may have not
messed with the color you know in a way
that
that felt like you know it was a color
challenge i want to look at it and know
like oh the
i want to say the color is awesome first
and foremost versus the render being
awesome first and foremost
um renders always get your points but
it's all about following that prompt so
congrats one dead duck this is great we
got one more
challenge winner this week and who's it
gonna be
boom this one right here by dave
uh this is freaking awesome i love
the subtle simple colors the render
quality is great
um you have the opposite colors in the
purple and the yellow
um the red and the cyan it's
it's freaking perfect yeah are you seen
it peter oh wow
yeah i just it just popped up that looks
amazing yeah
great color palette seriously um
yeah i dig this one really nice looks
real totally photo real
yeah that's amazing exactly
so dave congratulations you got the
challenge winner roll into the other
five of you guys
i guess the other four congrats keep it
up congrats y'all
yeah before we announce the uh
this week's challenge um which peter i
would love your help
coming up with um oh yeah i just want to
show you guys a couple
um runner-up renders that i thought were
sick
so let me go ahead and go ahead and turn
these off here um
and then just pull up some of these so
you have these ones here which i really
dug the color in it's like you have the
gold blue
orange blue kind of look um with the
cyans i think it looks really nice
um super super nice renders here
by these guys there's also a hidden
little peter 42
blood thing there which i
yeah that's a great render i love the
slightly cartoonish style
yeah me too it reminds me of breath of
the wild yeah
um next up let's see who do we got
bam these ones here very very colorful
so these ones are more vibrant yes
playing with yellows and reds and
uh like purples and stuff you guys are
doing a good job of like
bouncing back and forth between these
like the opposite colors on the color
wheel you're doing a really good job and
all these renders look really nice
i think um they all deserve a shout out
for sure
and especially the animated one too is
great whoa i love that washer one
it's sweet yeah me too
it's so good it's so good i love the
light
i know me too yeah that one's super
solid
yeah um and then one more chunk here
um boom boom
i love blue and gold
blue and yellow so much
and i dug these three renders um
the the one on the far right is probably
my favorite because it's like abstract
and like
super crazy looking and the colors are
just perfect uh
the house again wow yeah isn't that
crazy
oh my goodness that looks like it's from
that instagram page accidental wes
anderson oh i've never seen that but
that sounds great
oh it's great or maybe it's a subreddit
yeah the house against the mountain is
great and then i don't
i honestly don't know what the image is
on the bottom left
but i love the colors a lot so
i thought it was worth it oh is it a
skull is that a skull
maybe yeah actually i think it is
with some like banana goop coming out of
it or like banana feathers or something
i have no idea
that's really cool either way yeah um
so yeah guys congratulations to our
winners um
shout out regrets yeah yeah good times
what a stream dude honestly
a long one almost four hours
goodness serious i'm hearing people um
thinking about uh doing studio ghibli as
the render challenge did you already
have one in mind
no but that sounds great yeah people are
getting pumped about that
yeah let's do it um let's just do a
ghibli render challenge i don't think
we've done that in the past
i'm trying to think um i don't know if
deering is still on here
i'm sure enough you guys have done these
i don't think we've done ghibli before
right
because i think that'd be a great render
challenge
that way me and peter can finish our
renders and
you guys can post yours too all right we
haven't done it let's do it
studio ghibli oh yeah uh render
challenge this week you have one week
to either recreate a studio ghibli scene
um make your own style ghibli scene
uh the more you can model and texture
your own stuff from scratch the better
don't just download a scene and render
it you have till next saturday at 9 00
a.m pacific standard time
um don't plagiarize that's lame you'll
get banned
and exiled forever for doing that um
that's super like no no no
no no no um
awesome yeah well this was super fun man
thanks for having me on the stream right
let's do it again it was a good time
seriously dude um
have get some lunch get some water oh
i will be getting both of those things
right away heck yeah man
all right well uh i'll catch you later
peter and
guys thank you so much for doing this um
so yeah peter i'll see you monday i
guess yeah
hell yeah have a great weekend man yeah
you too all right later man
all right you saw my dude peace guys